Ich bin ein Kumpel, der in der Zeit nicht mehr ist. Ich bin ein Kumpel, der in der Zeit nicht mehr ist. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da.
Es hat irgendwie nicht wirklich funktioniert. Da dachte ich, es hat irgendwie was mit der Adresse zu tun, dass es irgendwie nicht über das normale Chat geht und so weiter.
Nö, das sollte eigentlich gehen. Manchmal gibt es noch ein bisschen Ärger mit den SSL-Settings und so. Können wir dir jetzt im Einzelnen aber nicht weiterhelfen? Muss mal schauen. Ich habe ein paar ganz sehr ausführliche und eigentlich mir immer alle Fragen beantwortende Seiten bei Google direkt gefunden, wie man das konfiguriert.
Das schöne am Instant Messaging ist übrigens, dass ich schöne Grüße ausrichten soll von Johnny Häusler. Der hat mich gerade angejabbert und bestellt schöne Grüße.
Warum jabbert er mich nicht an?
Weil er mich angejabbert hat.
Aha, na toll.
Was wolltest du sagen oder soll ich ein bisschen ans Telefon gehen?
Ich wollte mal kurz erwähnen, weil das jetzt gerade ganz gut passt. Also, wir hatten es jetzt schon mit Google. Also, Google hat vor... Wann ist denn das los? Vor einem Jahr? Mit Google Talk?
Unglaublich. Es gab so eine Anzeichen schon früher. Die haben sich auch ziemlich gut in die Community integriert. Also, sehr aktiv bei der Java Software Foundation. Schon diesen ganzen Open Source Konsortien, die du hast mit integriert, mitdiskutiert, auch teilweise eigene Standards gebaut, die offen sind.
24. August 2005 ging das irgendwie... Also genau vor einem Jahr haben sie eigentlich angefangen. So, und Google Talk ist halt auch eine Voice-Software, so eine Telefoniersoftware, aber sie bauen auf Java auf. Das heißt, auch das Audio-Protokoll, was sie machen, das ist publiziert und sehr viele Projekte, auch Open Source-Projekte, sind gerade dabei, dieses Protokoll auch einzubauen. Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, dass demnächst eben das erste, die ganzen Open Source-Dinger werden auf das selbe Protokoll wie Google gehen. Google war da halt mal wieder typisch klug, sag ich mal. Also, sie ist halt einfach eine der wenigen Firmen, die wirklich das mit dem Internet einfach verstanden hat. So, und deswegen sind sie halt auch so weit vorne. Aber jetzt folgen auch alle. Zum Beispiel, was wenige wissen, wenn ihr einen GMX-Account habt oder auch einen Web.de-Account, ich weiß nicht, gibt es noch andere?
Ja, das ist Freenet, hat ebenfalls einen Jabber-Server, da ist aber die Koppelung nicht da.
Okay.
Das ist der nächste Satz, ich wollte dir nicht vorgreifen.
Die Koppelung ist die, dass man im Prinzip, wie bei Google, eben mit seiner E-Mail-Adresse, mit seiner GMX-Adresse, auch da dort einen Jabber-Server hat. Da muss man mal, weiß nicht ganz genau, was man da jetzt in die Konfiguration eintragen muss, das habe ich mir noch nicht so genau angeschaut, aber es läuft dann halt auch ein Jabber-Server. Sprich, hat man einen GMX-Account, hat man auch gleich Jabber-Kommunikation. Man kann das einfach eintragen, wenn man sowieso schon mal einen Multiprotokoll-Client hat und auch GMX geht das eben out of the box. Aber man muss jetzt nicht bei so einem großen Hoster sein, um Jabber machen zu können. Das ist auch sehr einfach. Im Gegensatz zu den anderen Systemen, wo man sich dann halt, das haben wir ja schon gehört, mit endlosen, wer bist du, was weiß ich, wie heißt du, was sind deine Hobbies, irgendwie durch 100 Seiten durchklickt, um dann endlich mal diesen Dienst benutzen zu dürfen, ist bei Jabber diese Registrierungsfunktion auch schon mit im Protokoll mit drin. Das heißt, jeder normale Jabber-Client kann auch in der Regel einen gleichen Account machen. Man sagt halt nur, wo. Und dann gibt es eben zahlreiche öffentliche Jabber-Server, wo man sich einfach mal so eben einen Account machen kann. Zum Beispiel jabber.org. Auch der CCC hat einen eigenen Server, den Florian übrigens seinerzeit losgetreten hat. Da sollten wir vielleicht auch gleich nochmal drüber reden. Und dann kann man sich da eben einfach registrieren und dann hat man eben einen Account.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden? Also ich muss mich dann aber auch, also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel mein Freund Christoph aus Bonn auf einem anderen Jabber-Server seinen Account hat, ich habe den bei jabber.ccc.de, muss ich mich irgendwie mit dem noch austauschen. Also ich habe kein weltweites Netzwerk wie AIM, wo alle gleichzeitig drauf zu warten.
Ja, ja, doch, das ist einfach so. Stell dir vor wie E-Mail. Da gibt es ja auch viele verschiedene E-Mail-Server, die aber normalerweise trotzdem miteinander kommunizieren können. Genauso ist es bei Jabber immer auch. Die können miteinander reden, manchmal eben nicht. Es gibt da verschiedene Ausnahmefälle, wie bei E-Mail immer auch. Aber normalerweise kannst du es genau vergleichen. Also die reden untereinander, da hat es auch Standards dafür. Deswegen kannst du eben zum Beispiel von jabber.ccc.de aus auch auf Google zugreifen und auch umgekehrt.
Also eigentlich ist es der Normalfall. Der Normalfall ist, alle Jabber-Server reden miteinander. Bei Google war es am Anfang nicht so eine Weile. Da haben sie wohl noch getestet und danach haben sie sich aber auch geöffnet.
Das haben sie aber auch aktiv übrigens kommuniziert, dass sie es so tun, weil die unglaubliche Angst vor Spam hatten. Deswegen ging es auch in mehreren Schritten. So zuerst gegenüber altbekannten Jabber-Servern und dann die ganze Welt.
0331 77 97 110 ist unsere Nummer und der Jörg aus Kamen hat angerufen.
Ich würde ganz gerne über die sozialen Aspekte von Instant Messaging reden.
Gerne, ja.
Also zumindest im beruflichen Infield, wo ich diese augenlose Kommunikation eigentlich sehr sehr schätze. Da kann man relativ viel erreichen, ohne sich selbst jetzt mal anzufingen, die Böse zu geben. Allerdings nimmt ja auch Instant Messaging in vielerlei Formen, mittlerweile auch bei Support-Geschichten, Formen an. Also das habe ich jetzt zuletzt bei HP gemerkt, dass man seine Support-Anfragen etc. halt via Chat oder teilweise auch via Instant Messaging dann abklären kann. Und mein Werdegang zu Instant Messaging war eigentlich der, dass ich das dann irgendwann ganz proprietär übernommen habe, dass irgendwie jeder alte Q genutzt hat etc. Und da war eben alles neu und hat es dann eben alles gemacht. Und wenn die Dialoge eben länger geworden sind, ist es mir persönlich aufgefallen, dass dann auf einmal ich nicht mehr so drauf geachtet habe, ob ich jetzt groß und klein schreibe, ob meine Ausdrucksform jetzt die ist, wie ich sie zum Beispiel auch in einem fremdlichen Brief verwenden würde etc. Und naja, mit wachsender Kontaktliste etc. hat das dann eben insofern zugenommen, dass es mir mehr und mehr aufgefallen ist, dass ich mich bei Briefen zunehmend konzentrieren musste, wie ich schreibe oder bei Gesprächen mich wirklich auf meine Gesprächsführung konzentriert habe oder auch musste, weil eben diese zeitnahe Reaktion gefordert war. Und ich merke das jetzt zum Beispiel an jüngeren Familienmitgliedern oder ich arbeite halt auch in einer öffentlichen Einrichtung, da habe ich relativ viel mit Jugendlichen zu tun, dass viele, die wirklich Instant Messaging zur Kommunikation untereinander nutzen, auch ein Real-Life-Sprachgebot haben. Und das finde ich persönlich als erst mal negativen Aspekt, wenn dann die Sozialkompetenz darunter leidet.
Wie sieht ihr das denn?
Tja, ich kann das auch beobachten.
Na ja, da kamen jetzt halt gleich eine ganze Menge Themen. Als allererstes glaube ich mal der Unterschied zwischen Telefonieren und Instant Messaging, der ist natürlich da und beides hat Vor- und Nachteile. Also Instant Messaging geht einfach bei mir so im Grundrauschen unter. Wenn ich irgendwas am nebenher entwickeln bin, zwischendurch kompiliert es neu, dann kann ich währenddessen, soweit ich gerade zwei Minuten Zeit habe, die letzten vier Fragen, die dann noch irgendjemand an mich gestellt hat, beantworten, weitermachen. Beim Telefonieren wäre das natürlich total unhöflich, so jemanden immer wieder in die Watteschleife zu tun. Auf der anderen Seite, ich spreche ja leider aus Erfahrung, ist es eine total dämliche Idee, nicht mehr ganz nüchtern im Zustand im Instant Messaging unterwegs zu sein, aber wenn die Leute sich dann alle Bier anzunehmen, dann kriegen die es ja nicht mit, dass du gerade nicht mehr dich 100% unter Kontrolle hast und vielleicht ein bisschen mehr mit einem größeren daherkommst.
Da habe ich eine Ex von mir immer mit auf die Palme gekriegt, weil die mich nicht verstanden hat. Also was da konnotiert hat.
Beim Telefonieren hast du einfach die Untertöne oder in dem Moment dann immer auch das Lallen, dann ist dir einfach klar, wie ist der da drüben unterwegs. Es hat beides Vorteile, es hat beides Nachteile und es hat auch beides Sinn, behaupte ich.
Absolut, absolut. Nur, was ich eben mit Instant Messaging und dem Telefon in Verbindung bringen wollte, ist eben diese kontaktlose Kommunikation. Also klar, man hat das Hintergrundrauschen beim Telefonieren. Man hat vielleicht, wenn man sich diverse Chatlocks ansieht, auch den Sprachgebrauch beim Chat, oder im Doppel-R oder so, nur ich finde einfach, dass früher, ich sage mal früher, es ist ganz doof, es ist jetzt alles noch gar nicht so, so lange her, dass man da eigentlich einen Klang gefunden hat. Aber es war eben so, dass man sich ja schon immer was nicht getroffen hat oder halt auf dem Telefonat vorbereitet hat, weil eben alles teurer war. Und jetzt, wo alles quasi selbstverständlich wird oder teilweise ist, merke ich einfach mehr, wie soll ich das jetzt ausdringen. Und das, zum Beispiel die Jugendlich, mit denen ich da zu tun habe, zwar nicht direkt, ich bin halt Administrator manchmal in einem Computerraum, und da sehe ich dann einfach, wie die sich dann mit ihren Bewerbungen schreiben, zum Beispiel abkämpfen, eine große Kleinschreibung neidet denen darunter, bzw. auch die Formulierung. Und was ich immer wieder ganz lustig finde, ist, wenn man sich damit Leuten unterhält, und ich habs dann irgendwie mit denen im Brecht mal einen lustigen Witz zu machen, und dann dieses Loll oder Raffel.
Ja gut, ich meine, eine Veränderung der Kommunikation hat es bisher mit jedem Medium gegeben. Ich denke auch, das Telefon wird da einiges dazu beigetragen haben, um die Sprache zu vereinfachen und zu verkürzen. So, wenn man es jetzt mal so an ausufernden Briefen, die man früher geschrieben hat, vergleicht. Das ist natürlich ein Problem. Aber es ist eher ein Problem der Bildung und nicht so sehr das Instant Messaging, also der Ausbildung sozusagen. Also wenn man eine Ausbildung genießt, der jetzt keinen besonderen Wert gelegt darauf wird, dass man, egal wie man im Internet kommuniziert, trotzdem irgendwie ordentliches Lesen und Schreiben lernt, naja, dann bleibt das natürlich nicht aus. Aber ich finde es ein bisschen einfach, das dann sozusagen den neuen Entwicklungen vorzuwerfen, weil die kommen jetzt sowieso und da müssen wir uns irgendwie mit auseinandersetzen. Die Frage ist natürlich, inwieweit hat man jetzt einen Nachteil dadurch, wenn man das übertreibt?
Das ist richtig. Natürlich muss die entsprechende Bildung da vorhanden sein. Das sehe ich auch ein. Ich persönlich meine ja auch einfach nur, dass durch Ähnliches wie beim Fernsehen, dass man einfach auch darauf achten muss. Die Aufklärung insofern, ich meine, das ist natürlich doof, Instant Messaging, Kommunikation und dann Aufklärung etc. Aber ich finde es irgendwo schon wichtig, oder fände es für mich persönlich auch wichtig, wenn man einfach so ein bisschen damit aufwächst, dass man darauf achtet, wie und wo man jetzt kommuniziert. Natürlich ist das vielleicht bei Gleichgesinnten, bei älteren Menschen, die das vielleicht erst im Nachhinein so mitkriegen, kein Problem, weil dann die dementsprechende Praxis auch vorherrscht. Aber wenn ich das jetzt zum Beispiel bei meinen jüngeren Cousins miterlebe, die jetzt ungefähr 11 und 16, 17 sind, die wachsen ja damit auf. Und dann ist halt dieses obligatorische Roffel und Loll erstmal integriert und das dann irgendwo auch aus dem Sprachgebrauch, wenn man zumindest jetzt im Klagsegen ineinander spricht, weil man einfach Familie ist, finde ich, ist das schon relativ schwer.
Naja, aber das ist ja ein Stück weit auch einfach eine Altersfrage. Ich meine, man entwickelt sich immer weiter. Und wenn ich mir heute E-Mails anschaue, die ich mit 16 geschrieben habe, die sind mir auch furchtbar peinlich. Also gerade in dem Alter würde ich es auch nicht allzu sehr überbewerten. Wir hatten ja alle irgendwelche Ausdrücke, die unsere Eltern nicht leiden konnten. Und dementsprechend ist es jetzt eben diese Instant-Messaging-Sprache. Aber zu viel Gedanken würde ich mir da auch nicht umsauen.
Ja, ich bin auch eher unbeunruhigt.
Also wirklich unruhig bin ich an sich nicht. Weil natürlich hat man das alles schon überall mal gesehen, mit dem Handy etc. Das ist schon richtig. Aber ich merke es bei mir einfach persönlich. Das wollte ich einfach damit ansprechen, dass ich da auch für mich eine Veränderung mitgemacht habe. Auch was, was ich in meinem sozialen Umfeld sehe.
Und was ist jetzt die Konsequenz daraus für dich?
Dass ich einfach auch bewusst habe versucht dagegen zu wirken.
Naja, man kann es ja auch andersrum machen. Also gerade in Neuseeland ist ja an den Schulen jetzt offiziell zugelassen, dass du diese Chatakronyme verwenden darfst. Ich hab's für einen völligen Quatsch auf Deutsch gesagt, aber es gibt natürlich verschiedene Wege damit umzugehen. Und das Problem wird ja offensichtlich auch von den Verantwortlichen erkannt, wenn eben solche Vorstöße sind. Ob man die jetzt gut oder schlecht findet, sei dahingestellt. Aber wir leben in einer schnellen Zeit. Da ändert sich viel und da müssen wir einfach gucken, wie wir damit umgehen.
Ja, das war ja auch vorher schon mit E-Mails so. Also Instant Messaging mag da vielleicht nochmal was drauflegen. Das stimmt schon.
Wie hattet ihr denn euren sozialen, also den Real Life oder überhaupt den sozialen Kontakt in Bezug auf die Nutzung von Instant Messaging? Weil ich persönlich merke eigentlich, dass ich behaupte jetzt einfach, dass ich 90% meines Sozialkontaktes den pflege über Instant Messaging.
Naja, sowohl als auch. Also ich meine, du hast natürlich im Instant Messaging immer so Kaliber, die hinter dieser vermeintlichen Anonymität ihr normales Verhalten verstecken und dementsprechend unglaublich freundlich, um es mal möglichst positiv auszudrücken, Verhalten, also einfach Idioten sind, die normal, wenn sie dir gegenüberstehen, sich wesentlich anders verhalten würden. Das hast du immer, aber normale Freundschaften pflegen, da gehört auch einfach das abendliche Bier dazu, da gehört auch mit anderen ins Kino gehen dazu, und das kann Instant Messaging nicht ersetzen, das kann es höchstens ergänzen, dass er da eben den Termin abmacht.
So ein Saufen vor dem EM-Klein habe ich auch schon gemacht. Mit einem Freund, der 600 Kilometer entfernt ist.
Bitte nimm die Hand aus dem Schritt, bevor du mit mir chattest. Ich würde auch mal ein paar ganz positive Aspekte machen. Instant Messaging dreht natürlich auch mit anderen Kulturen zusammen. Wir erleben ja heutzutage eh schon diesen Trend hin zu Sprachenlernen im Internet, weil man sowieso das muss und Instant Messaging setzt natürlich nochmal die Kommunikationsschwelle sehr viel niedriger. Man kommt noch sehr viel weniger aus. Ich muss jetzt eben nicht überlegen, wie komponiere ich meine E-Mail in dieser Sprache. Man kann es halt auch einfach mal probieren, ob das jeder so macht. Ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Option, die da noch mit dazu kommt.
Also das kann ich insofern auch nur unterstreichen, dass ich der E-Mail-Kontakte gerade für... Also aktuell ist es bei mir mit einer Zertifizierungsprüfung, dass ich da viele Lerngruppen in meinen Fingern so kennengelernt habe. Also einfach, was weiß ich, die ICQ oder sowas, irgendwo in einem Blog stand oder in einem Forum beitrat. Und insofern konnte man natürlich sehr einfach in Kontakt treten. Das unterschreibe ich so, das sehe ich genauso. Ich fand es jetzt für mich einfach nur sehr bemerkenswert, dass ich viele... Also ich sage jetzt einfach mal diese althergebrachte Kontaktpflege, dass ich anstatt anrufen mal eben schreibe, hey, wie geht es dir? Und man quatscht mal ein bisschen über alte Zeiten manchmal. Und klar, man trifft dich auch irgendwo. Aber bei mir ist wirklich ein Großteil der Pflege auf Instant Messaging gewichen oder ausgewichen.
Ist das jetzt gut oder ist das schlecht?
Ich persönlich finde es sehr angenehm, muss ich ehrlich sagen, weil diese Echtzeitkommunikation hat natürlich wesentliche Vorteile, was jetzt manchmal das eigene Verhältnis angeht. Ich kann klar schreiben, ich bin gleich wieder da, und der kann mich zutexten und ich gehe eben duschen, und dann kann ich wieder lesen, beantworten etc. Das ist natürlich klasse. Auch spontane Fragestellungen. Wenn ich jetzt manchmal auch etwas programmiere, ich habe jetzt eine Schwierigkeit, wo ich weiß, dass der und der das schon gelöst hat, dann kann ich ihn natürlich mal eben anschreiben, und er schickt mir dann irgendwie die Lösung zu. Das ist eine absolut geniale Geschichte. Aber ich finde es insofern eben auch gefährlich, weil ich merke, dass ich mich teilweise auch so ein bisschen darauf ausruhe, weil wenn ich dann irgendwie mein Fing 3 Stunden mit einem in Kontakt stehe, und man sich dann wirklich auch ausgiebig unterhält über Gott und die Welt, und was noch alles dazugehört, dann hat das für mich schon wirklich so einen Charakter von wir haben uns jetzt mal getroffen. Natürlich ersetzt das das echte Treffen nicht, irgendwo an einem Kno oder so, aber ich finde, es nimmt vieles von diesen spontanen Besuchen, oder von dieser spontanen Bereitschaft, bei mir zumindest ab. Dass ich also jetzt nicht auf den Gedanken komme, ich weiß, ich bin vorbei, weil habe ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, weil wir haben ja in den letzten drei Stunden gegeneinander gechattet.
Ich finde aber, gut, dass du das sagst, weil ich finde, es kommt auch eine neue Qualität dazu. Also was ich sehr häufig habe, das sind so Gespräche, die über den Tag laufen. Etwas, was ich einfach so in Real-Life-Kommunikation überhaupt gar nicht haben könnte und was auch mit E-Mail irgendwie so nicht möglich ist. Man ist halt immer so irgendwie online, man sieht sich so und es gibt dann auch tatsächlich so ein Thema, aber es gibt nicht genug her und man ist auch gar nicht so wach genug dabei oder hat vielleicht auch einfach seine ganzen Schlussfolgerungen noch so gar nicht beisammen, um da einfach mal drüber zu reden, aber dann schreibt so jeder in einer halben Stunde dann mal irgendwie so eine Erkenntnis und dann kommt irgendwie eine Erkenntnis zurück und dann kommt wieder eine Erkenntnis zurück und dann tippelt man auch ein bisschen intensiver hin und her und dann ist wieder mal drei Stunden Pause und dann am Abend kommt man mal wieder drauf. Und am Ende hat man dann so vielleicht nur 20 Sätze ausgetauscht, aber so eine gewisse Essenz, wie man sich gerade wegen irgendeines Ereignisses fühlt oder Entscheidungen, die anstehen, wo man irgendwie Unterstützung braucht, so eine Sache. Also auch wirklich so extrem intersoziales, wo es jetzt nicht um Technik oder irgendeinen anderen Glimp, oder gehen wir jetzt mal ins Kino geht. Das wiederum finde ich, kann man damit auch ganz gut machen. Man muss natürlich schon über die Grenzen auch im Klaren sein. Man sollte sich auch wissen, sicher sein, dass auf der einen Seite nur einer sitzt und nicht fünf.
Und dann bist du auch noch der Richtige.
Und dann bist du noch der Richtige, genau. Aber weißt du, was ich meine? Also das kommt auf jeden Fall noch mit rein. Also es ist wie mit allen Kommunikationsmedien. Man braucht die nötige Medienkompetenz. Die kann man sich nur erarbeiten, indem man es halt auch einfach mal tut. Und danach muss man eben auch dann selber klar sehen, okay, das funktioniert prima, das funktioniert damit gar nicht. Das lasse ich damit auch mal sein. Und manchmal ist es dann halt auch irgendwie Real-World. Aber dieses Real-World-Gefeiere finde ich manchmal auch ein bisschen übertrieben. Man muss auch irgendwie schauen, was die Kommunikationsmittel dann für eben neue Kommunikationsformen auch schaffen.
Absolut. Ich finde auch, dass, also das sehe ich ja einfach, dass öfter mal, wenn ich mich dann treffe, dann treffe ich mich auch wirklich mit der Person. Und dann fallen viele Dinge einfach wie eben diese 20 Sätze, die man halt über den Tag verteilt miteinander gequatscht hat, einfach mal weg. Man kann sich dann über den Kinofilm unterhalten. Dann hat das irgendwie eine ausgedehntere Diskussionsgrundlage geworden. Oder ich persönlich fühle mich dann meistens, wenn diese Sätze vorher nicht gesprochen wurden, immer so ein bisschen dazu gedrängt. Auch über das zu sprechen, was mir denn jetzt gerade am Herzen liegt, was ich eigentlich mal mitteilen wollte. Und halt solche Nebensächlichkeiten vielleicht, die jetzt gar nicht so existenziell sind, die jetzt von mir aus auch die wenige Zeit, die man sich dann manchmal mal sieht, ausfüllen würde. Das fällt dann weg. Man kann sich dann wirklich darüber unterhalten. Mensch, wie war denn der Film? Keine Ahnung, man trinkt halt ein Bierchen, redet ein bisschen dumm zu euch und so. Macht dann für mich einen sehr unbefangeneren Eindruck, wenn ich mich dann wirklich real live treffe.
Und gute Nacht.
Ja, euch auch.
Danke. Ich bin Gott.
Also alle, die mir kennen und mir mögen und mir auch mal sehen wollen, können ja mal bei mir anrufen.
Miete von Mia. Wir sind im Moment auf Tour, deswegen könnt ihr mich gerade nicht erreichen. Wir spielen uns fleißig den Arsch wund mit vier sagen Lügen und wenn ihr überhaupt irgendwas über die Konzerte noch wissen wollt, dann fragt doch am besten die Fritzen.
Die Fritz präsentiert Mia. Gleich zweimal live in Berlin. Samstag neunter und Sonntag zehntner Dezember.
Das Bundeskabinett hat die Rente mit 67 beschlossen. Der Gesetzentwurf zur Alterssicherung sieht die schrittweise Anhebung des Rentenalters von 65 auf 67 Jahre zwischen den Jahren 2012 und 2029 vor. Damit verbunden ist eine Beschäftigungsinitiative für Ältere. Langjährig Versicherte, die mindestens 45 Jahre Beiträge gezahlt haben, sollen weiterhin mit 65 Jahren abschlagsfrei in Rente gehen können. Noch vor Weihnachten soll der Entwurf in erster Lesung im Bundestag beraten werden. Bei den Ermittlungen um den Tod des Kreml-Kritikers Litvinenko sind nun auch an Bord von Passagierflugzeugen der Fluggesellschaft British Airways Spuren einer radioaktiven Substanz entdeckt worden. Die betroffenen drei Maschinen waren laut British Airways auf der Strecke London-Moscow im Einsatz. Nach Informationen der BBC handelt es sich bei der gefundenen Substanz um Polonium-210. Litvinenko war mit dieser Substanz vergiftet worden. Seither wurden Spuren davon an mehreren Orten in London festgestellt. Die globale Klimaerwärmung beschäftigt erstmals auch das oberste Gericht in den USA. 12 Bundesstaaten und 13 Umweltorganisationen klagen gegen die US-Bundesumweltbehörde, die den Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen wie Kohlendioxid aus Fahrzeugen regulieren soll. Der Kläger argumentieren, dass die rund 240 Millionen registrierten Kraftfahrzeuge für ein Viertel der Treibhausgase in den USA verantwortlich sind. Der damit verbundene Klimawandel gefährde die öffentliche Gesundheit. Zum Sport, die Basketballer von Alba Berlin haben im Julep Cup die erste Heimliederlage hinnehmen müssen. Der deutsche Vizemeister verlor gegen Haapuel Jerusalem mit 77 zu 92. Im Fußball UEFA Pokal unterlag Bayer Leverkusen am vierten Spieltag der Gruppe B bei Dynamo Bukarest mit 1 zu 2. Heute Nacht lockert es von Westen näher auf, dazu gibt es Tiefstwerte von 7 bis 3 Grad. Der Tag beginnt stellenweise mit Nebel, später dann Wolken, ab und zu auch bei Sonne bei 7 bis 9 Grad. A24 Berliner Ring Richtung Schwerin zwischen drei Quid-Stock-Dosse und Tankstelle mit Kiosk Stolpe ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, der nicht überholt werden kann. A100 Stadtring Berlin, Wilmersdorf Richtung Neukölln zwischen Albuinstraße und Tempelhofer Dam ist der rechte Fahrstreifen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt und A115A Wurst-Nutetal Richtung Funkturm. In Höhe Hüttenweg ist der rechte Fahrstreifen ebenfalls wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Mario, 4,512.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
Und angerufen hat der Tech-Alo-Tech. Ich wollte mal auf das Thema aufmerksam machen, dass irgendwie ziemlich viele Jabber-User, die jetzt zu Jabber wechseln wollen, ein Riesenproblem haben, einen Client und einen sinnvollen Server zu finden. Und dass da irgendwie noch nicht wirklich die vernünftige Übersichtsseite zugibt.
Also zu Clients findest du direkt bei der Wikipedia eine Übersicht.
Aber zu Servern, also gerade jetzt zur XMPP-Net gibt es zwar, aber irgendwie, was ich so auf meinem Umfeld halt kenne, von Freunden, die finden das einfach nicht. Die haben einfach sagen, ja gut, jetzt versuche ich mal Jabber, probiere es aus. Dann nudeln sie fünf Minuten dran rum und am Ende sagen sie, ach, ist mir zu blöd, ich kann das nicht.
Das stimmt, das erklärt sich schlecht selbst, ja, das ist richtig.
Was ich auch großartig habe, betreibe ich momentan selber einen Jabber-Server, weil ziemlich viele, die ich jetzt überredet habe, sagen, dass sie an anderen Freunden Kontakt über ICQ und MSN halten wollen und da sind halt auch noch Gateways drauf und dann können sie es halt, wenn man es denen eingerichtet hat. Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie der Rechner neu installiert werden soll und der Klein dann wieder drauf gepackt wird, dann haben sie ihr Login vergessen. Und dann kommt halt so, ich möchte das und das Passwort per E-Mail im Klientext hingeschickt und irgendwie nicht so, was man sich so gerade wünscht.
Das erklärt sich tatsächlich relativ schlecht selbst. Also du hast so bei ICQ und bei diesen Proprietärin-Systemen immer den Vorteil, du hast so Download Client, installier und läuft und macht alles, was es machen soll. Und du musst dich vor allen Dingen nicht damit auseinandersetzen, was hinter dem Client passiert.
Ja, das mit Sicherheit. Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, die Proprietären-Protokolle haben einfach mal ein Jahrzehnt Vorsprung. Und dementsprechend, Jabber ist noch in diesem klassischen, ich nenne es mal, Open Source-Stadium, wo einfach... Ich wollte es jetzt mal freundlicher formulieren, aber du hast vollkommen recht. Das ist einfach Technik entwickeln für Techniker. Man bietet einfach mal jede theoretisch mögliche Option an. Man streitet sich über die obskursten Probleme. Ja, genau, genau. Und TLS und wie sie alle heißen. Und dazu kommen natürlich ganz viele Emotionen. Jeder steht hinter seinem Baby. Jeder hat den coolsten Jabber-Demon, den coolsten Jabber-Server, den coolsten Client geschrieben. Es gibt wenig schmerzhaftere Dinge in der Jabber-Welt, als zu sagen, ich finde das gut und das schlecht. Ich habe den Fehler ein paar Mal gemacht. Ich habe jedes Mal eins auf die Nase gekriegt. Ich bin inzwischen vorsichtig geworden. Und deswegen, es ist noch ein bisschen unübersichtlich, die Landschaft. Aber es wird besser, es wird einfach schon deswegen besser, weil inzwischen auch ganz eine Menge Firmen dabei sind. Und die haben dann eben Marketing und die haben dann Sales-Druiden und, und, und. Die machen das dann schön bunt und mit Bildern und mit Filmen. Und es wird mit Sicherheit besser. Es ist ja auch heute. Ich meine, schau dir die aktuellen Jabber-Clients an, vergleiche mit denen von vor zwei Jahren.
Ja, das große Problem, was ich auch immer so sehe, irgendwie, wenn man dem jetzt meines Wings Psy als Klein bei Windows aufgeschwatzt hat, dann sagen sie halt auch, ja gut, jetzt habe ich nur Psy drauf. Meine drei Clients eigentlich schon spüren mich nicht, wenn ich jetzt ICQ, MSN und so alles gleichzeitig habe. Und da habe ich aber dieses Spiel da nicht drin, weil die anderen Clients haben halt irgendwie so eine Kleinklicky-Bunti-Spiele. Und das ist dann irgendwie meistens so aussagekräftig für die, dass die sagen, ah, so ein Spiel hatte es, Jabber hat keine Spiele, finde ich würde.
Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Es hängt eben vom Kleinen ab. Es gibt da verschiedene Standards, es gibt da verschiedene Entwürfe, es gibt verschiedene Clients, aber wie gesagt, es steckt alles in Kinderschuhen. Also mit gutem Gewissen was empfehlen, was da draußen ist und was viele schon können, kann man nicht. Aber es kommt, es gibt auch schon die Ideen dazu, es ist wirklich nur noch eine Freude Zeit.
Naja, die Verbreitung muss einfach noch ein bisschen mehr fortschreiten.
Und es muss ein bisschen bunter werden und halb so viele Konfigurationsoptionen, dann funktioniert es auch.
Aber sonst ist eigentlich, was ich auch so, ich betreibe halt selber auch einen Server und irgendwie ist es halt auch ein Problem, dass die meisten keine oder überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, wie sie sich überhaupt auch registrieren sollen, weil dann kommt wirklich dann die Passworte per E-Mail und jetzt habe ich bei mir konkret halt so gemacht, dass ich im Web-Fontent halt ein kleines Applet reingesetzt habe, wo man halt sich per SSL-Verschuss jetzt irgendwie so einen Account anlegt und dann irgendwie Step-by-Step erklärt ist für ein paar Messenger, wie man da halt dran rankommt. Das funktioniert dann laut Feedback halt ziemlich gut jetzt in letzter Zeit, aber irgendwie das haben noch nicht die meisten Server und das ist halt auch irgendwie so ein Ding.
Für wen ist denn ein Server?
Der Server ist momentan eigentlich habe ich angefangen, hauptsächlich für mich. Da hatte noch keine Geldweste gehabt, dann haben ein paar Freunde halt gesagt, ja probiere ich mal aus, dann habe ich die halt davon überzeugt, es sind irgendwie so um die 50 Leute drauf. Das ist leider momentan noch hinter ADSL und hinter DynIP. Das ist halt ein bisschen blöde, aber da die Server eigentlich gerade DNS-Caching hatte ich bis jetzt irgendwie komischerweise noch keine Probleme.
Mit anderen Worten, du betreibst das sozusagen von zu Hause aus?
Privat genau, aber schon ein bisschen professioneller. Also der Server ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so eine komische Medienkiste, sondern das ist schon ein bisschen mit Raid und allem drum und dran. Nur halt bei mir kommt jetzt bald VDSL und ein fester IP und dann kann man da irgendwie schon sagen, dass man das besser hinkriegt.
Aber das ist doch gerade die Idee hinter Jabber. Ich meine, dass du eben dezentral viele kleine Server tust. Und deswegen, du schießt dir im Prinzip mit dem Protokoll selber in den Fuß, wenn du jetzt sagst, dieser Jabber-Server ist der Coolste der Welt und da wollen wir hin. Dementsprechend, es ist halt immer so eine wirklich einfache Antwort auf die Fragen. Gibt es nicht vor allem, wie sieht ein guter Server aus? Da hat auch schon jeder eine andere Antwort.
Ja, was soll der vor allem auch bieten? Und wenn man überlegt, von dem Benutzerzweig, also CCCD hat ja jetzt auch keine kaum Gateways mehr, also ICQ ist ja auch jetzt weg und so.
Ja, die Platte ist kaputt. Die befindet sich übrigens neben mir in meinem Rucksack, die kaputte Platte. Die habe ich gestern wieder mit nach Berlin gebracht.
Aber gerade, also vorher waren halt auch ein paar Leute auf CCCD und die haben dann halt gesehen, ah Mist, jetzt kann ich nicht mehr mit meinen Freunden chatten. Und dann sind die halt auch immer irgendwie abgewandert und sind komplett teilweise auch von Jabber dann weggegangen, weil irgendwie sowas auch nicht irgendwie gut geregelt ist. Das wäre ja auch so noch eine Frage, unter Umständen. Wie, also welche Clients implementieren jetzt schon irgendwelche Whiteboards oder so? Also das würde mich mal interessieren, weil ich habe da noch nichts Sinnvolles so gefunden. Also dass man jetzt irgendwie mal zwingend so ein Fenster hat, wo man drauf rumschmieren kann, wie eine Tafel.
Also der einzige, von dem ich sicher weiß, ist dieser Cochinella, Cochinella, keine Ahnung, wie man den korrekt ausspricht. Äh, ansonsten, ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein Linux-Client. Muss ich danach googeln. Ist, glaube ich, sogar auf der Chaosradio-Seite irgendwo erwähnt. Das ist ein richtiger Jabber-Standard. Und ich bin irgendwann mal über einen Flash-Blasiert gestolpert, der das auch konnte. Aber so wirklich viele sind es auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber es gibt einen Standard und es gibt ein paar Clients, die es implementieren.
Ein Whiteboard, worauf man rumschmieren kann, habe ich irgendwas verpasst.
Ja, also da war jetzt sehr viel drin.
Cool, positiv, auf jeden Fall.
Also Java, wir erwähnen es auch immer wieder gerne, weil es ist einfach die Zukunft. Das Schöne an Java ist, es ist einfach sehr offen für Neues, für neue Entwicklungen. Das Protokoll ist an sich schon erweiterbar ausgelegt. Und es gibt sehr viele Dienste, die so im Hintergrund schlummern, die heute noch von kaum jemandem benutzt werden, außer von den Leuten, die wirklich genau wissen, was man damit tun können wird. Aber das wird sich sehr schnell entwickeln. Jetzt, wo Google dahinter steht und auch andere große Firmen schrittweise wechseln und diese Userbase sozusagen von sich aus größer wird. Viele wechseln halt einfach, das haben wir jetzt schon ein paar Mal gehört, ich gehe nicht, weil meine Freunde sind ja auch auf ICQ. Aber irgendwann werden dann halt viele Freunde eben auch auf Java sein, dann wird das eben ganz natürlich von A nach B emigrieren. Da sehe ich gar kein Problem. Aber Java bietet halt auch eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten, die man erwähnen sollte, die nicht ganz unwichtig sind, die einen vielleicht auch schon jetzt schon dazu bringen können. Eins zum Beispiel, das haben wir jetzt eben schon gehört, man kann halt so seinen eigenen Server betreiben. Gut, das ist nicht unbedingt jedermanns Sache. Hat aber natürlich, wenn man es kann, oder wenn man jemanden findet, der es für einen tut, verschiedene Vorteile. Erstmal, da ist man unter sich. Also viele haben ja auch Angst wegen Abhören und tralala, wer kriegt das mit und so weiter. Hat man seinen eigenen Server im Netz laufen, so wie man heute auch seinen eigenen Web-Server laufen hat, dann hat man auch seine Kommunikation unter Kontrolle. Zumindest, solange sie diesen Server nicht verlässt.
Das ist vor allem für Firmen übrigens sehr interessant, weil da geht es ja wirklich um Geld, um geistiges Eigentum und diese ganze Diskussion. Richtig.
Und da kann man dann auch verschiedene Dinge sicherstellen, wo man sich sonst nicht so sicher sein kann. Darauf aufbauend, das haben wir ja schon erwähnt, hat eben Java auch so eine dezentrale Struktur, aber ICQ und so weiter, da geht eben alles über deren zentrale Server, also deren im Sinne von die Firmen, die das betreiben. Und da weiß man eben auch nicht, was da abgeht, beziehungsweise teilweise sind die ja auch ganz unverblümt. Also so in den Nutzungsbedingungen von ICQ, wenn man da mal so blättert, da steht dann einfach so drin, ach ja, übrigens, wenn du irgendwelches Copyright-Material über unsere Kanäle rüber schickst, dann gehört das uns.
So, ja, scheiß Traum. Ja, somit werden wir sie verklauseln. Also sehr deutlich stand es eine Zeit lang bei AOL drin, bei AEM. Da stand also wirklich, you waive any right for privacy. Also du hast einfach verloren, du gibst uns alle Rechte. Das stand wörtlich so in den Terms of Service drin. Das gab natürlich massiven Protest, als es dann irgendwie nach acht Wochen jemand entdeckt hat, weil so ein Quatsch schließt ein normaler Mensch. Und dann haben sie das so ein bisschen umgedealt. Ja, und es wäre ja nur für die Foreneinträge gemeint, nur das, was zur Public irgendwo mitteilst und die direkte Kommunikation wird, davon nicht betroffen. Aber ich meine, unabhängig davon, was sie da reinschreiben, du hast keine Ahnung, was sie tatsächlich mitlesen, was sie damit tun. Und ich meine, das Datenschutzrecht in den USA, das stehen einfach die meisten Server. Das ist ja hinreichend bekannt. Das ist einfach wesentlich schlechter, als es hier in Europa noch ist.
Tja, Leute, macht euch klar, das sind Riesenunternehmen. Microsoft, AOL, Yahoo, es geht einfach nicht größer. Und die bieten euch das alles kostenlos an.
Warum wohl?
Okay, ich kann verhindern, dass AOL Data Mining in meinen Instant Messaging Chats betreibt, aber woher weiß ich denn, dass jetzt, wenn ich einen kleinen Server betreibe, Max Mütze betreibt einen kleinen Server und die alle sprechen auch noch mit JabberCCCDE, woher weiß ich denn nicht, dass jetzt bei Max Mütze oder bei mir oder bei JabberCCCDE auch jemand sitzt, der mitliest?
Na ja, da gibt es eigentlich zwei verschiedene Antworten. Die erste ist speziell bei JabberCCCDE, da hat es eine richtig tolle Website, wo ganz genau draufsteht, was technisch möglich ist, was wir loggen, was wir mitlesen könnten, was wir auch teilweise einfach zu Debugging-Zwecken mitlesen, wobei mir der Inhalt der Nachrichten auch herzlich egal ist. Und vor allem, Jabber hat im Standard verschiedene Ansätze zu einer Verschlüsselung von Ende zu Ende. Das heißt, da sehe ich nur noch Datenmüll, da sehe ich nur noch Buchstaben durchfliegen, die keinen Sinn ergeben und ich kann jeden nur raten, benutze es. Erstens, es interessiert mich nicht, was da drinsteht, das heißt, ich will es auch gar nicht lesen. Und dementsprechend Jabber ist einfach in der Richtung sehr viel besser, weil du direkt im Standard drin schon verschiedene Ansätze zu Verschlüsselungen hast, dass einfach ein Administrator nichts mehr lesen kann. Der kann zwar die Verbindungsdaten sehen, also von wann bis wann hast du mit wem kommuniziert, aber der interessante Teil, worüber, worum ging es, der ist eben einfach nicht mehr lesbar. Und vor allem, du hast auf der anderen Seite eben auch die Authentifikation, da sitzt keiner dazwischen, der da nichts verloren hat, weil du eben auf beiden Seiten eine Signatur hast, auf beiden Seiten ein Schlüssel, der da ausgetauscht wird. Dementsprechend, da gibt es schon bei Jabber verschiedene Mechanismen, die du bei den proprietären Messengern nur teilweise hast.
Kann Mabba, also der HTML-Jabber, kleint das auch? Also verschlüsselt der auch oder tippe ich da lesbar rein?
Da tippst du natürlich lesbar an. Das ist direkt, fällt dann ins HTTP rein.
Man muss zwei Verschlüsselungsarten unterscheiden. Das eine ist, was das Netz von sich aus tut und das andere ist, was man halt selbst tut. Wenn ich mit dir rede, dann können wir das halt auch verschlüsselt tun. Die Server verschlüsseln sozusagen nur die Wege durch die Server hindurch, im besten Fall. Auch nicht unbedingt immer, aber wir können ja sicherstellen, dass unsere Kommunikation auch nochmal verschlüsselt ist. Es gibt bisher, kann man das so sagen, zwei verschiedene populäre Methoden, wie man das macht.
Es gibt drei, aber die dritte hat kein Mensch implementiert. Typisches Jabber-Problem. Es gibt eigentlich zwei, ja.
Was sind denn die dritte?
Die dritte ist so ein richtig jabbereigener Standard, aber...
Ach so, dann gibt es vier. Da ist auch noch gerade einer eingefallen. Gehen wir so vielleicht mal kurz durch. Also aus der E-Mail-Welt kommt GPG, oder PGP, je nachdem, wie man es lesen möchte, von rechts nach rechts oder von rechts nach links. Das ist quasi auf derselben Public-Private-Key-Verschlüsselungsmethode, wie man eben auch seine E-Mail sichern kann. Gibt es auch Clients, Java-Clients oder auch andere E-M-Clients, die eben auch das unterstützen. Das heißt, wir tauschen sozusagen unsere öffentlichen Schlüssel aus und dann kommuniziere ich halt mit dir, indem ich eben für dich alles verschlüssel und du verschlüsselst alles für mich. Das kennt man erstmal und das klingt natürlich auch alles ganz logisch. Das ist es natürlich auch. Es gibt aber Leute, die sagen, okay, bei Instant Messaging, da geht aber sehr viel hin und her. Da möchte ich eigentlich auch noch mehr verhindern, als nur, dass keiner mitliest. Da gibt es einen interessanten Ansatz zu, das ist das sogenannte Off-the-Record-Verschlüsselungsprotokoll, das explizit für Instant Messaging gemacht ist, also für E-Mail nicht so taugt, aber bei Instant Messaging voll seine Qualitäten entfalten kann. Das hat nämlich verschiedene grundlegende Features. Erstmal die Verschlüsselung als solche, aber dann ist es auch so, dass während man so hin und her chatet, permanent neue Schlüssel ausgetauscht werden. Dadurch verhindert man, dass, wenn ein Schlüssel mal bekannt wird, dass man darauf sofort auf alles andere schließen kann. Es gibt also eine permanente weitere Verschlüsselung, und wenn man irgendwo zwischendurch aufsetzt, dann gibt es keinen Schlüssel, den man irgendwie kennen kann. Dann kann man alles entschlüsseln. Bei GPG ist es so, ist der private Schlüssel einmal offen, dann kann man die gesamte Kommunikation auch noch Wochen, Monate und Jahre und Jahrhunderte später aufdecken.
Also mal angenommen, ich habe zu ersten Dialog geführt, anschließend habe ich die Hausdurchsuchung und die finden da den Schlüssel, dann können sie trotzdem gucken, was ich schon vor vier Wochen kommuniziert habe.
Genau. Außerdem sieht das Protokoll vor, dass man auch alles abstreiten kann. Das heißt, wenn ich mit dir kommuniziere und du liest das ja sozusagen unverschlüsselt wieder, was ich getippt habe, und du gehst jetzt irgendwie zu den Bullen und sagst, hier Tim, so geht es ja gar nicht, dann kann ich sagen, es ist technisch möglich, dass du eine Software benutzt, die nur behauptet, ich hätte das gesagt. Das heißt, das Verschlüsselungsprotokoll sieht explizit die Deniability vor. Ich kann das einfach bestreiten und kann auf das Protokoll verweisen und sagen, es ist möglich, so zu tun, als wäre das geschehen, das, was er euch gezeigt hat, ist kein Beweis, auch wenn er das sozusagen kryptographisch belegen möchte.
Der Trick dabei ist nämlich ganz einfach der, dass diese Schlüssel, die da laufend ausgetauscht werden, die werden immer anschließend, also der letzte, den wir getauscht haben, wird bei der nächsten Nachricht einfach mit dem Gegenüber zugeschickt und damit kann er nachträglich also beliebige andere Sachen konstruieren. Während du bei GNU-PG, bei GPG, PGP, wie auch immer, da hast du eine Signatur dabei. Das heißt, du kannst nachher klar nachweisen, da ist die Signatur gültig, der Inhalt ist tatsächlich von dem Menschen, der diesen privaten Key eben in den Fingern hat, ist in dem Fall also tatsächlich von Tim.
Und es ist auch eine sehr unkomplizierte Geschichte. Man kann das halt an den Kleinstil das unterstützen. Gaim, den haben wir ja schon mal erwähnt, ist so ein Ding, da gibt es ein Plug-in, das unterstützt das einfach.
Adium macht das auch, ne, für Mängelwischen.
Genau, weil der auch auf Gaim basiert. Und da kann man das halt einfach so einschalten, kann sagen, ok, ich erzeug mir jetzt einen Schlüssel, dann wird der so on the fly erzeugt. Dann hat man dafür einen Fingerabdruck, so eine zusammengefasste Zahl, die quasi belegt, dass das der Schlüssel ist, an der man das überprüfen kann. So, dann können wir halt einfach mal verschlüsselte Kommunikation einschalten und los geht's. Und jedes Mal, wenn wir irgendwie miteinander reden, kann man dann seinen Kleinen so einstellen, ok, wenn Heugi kommt, dann sofort gleich wieder verschlüsseln. Sodass man eben automatisch immer so eine End-to-End-Verschlüsselung hat. Mit jedem hat man irgendwie einen anderen Key, permanent ändert sich alles und man kann sogar alles abstreiten.
In einer idealen Welt.
Ach deine Lampe leuchtet auch, das ist gut.
Ich wollte dich nochmal befragen, die Lampe am Erleuchtenden, das ist toll, das reflektiert sich.
Auf java.org, der Webseite, die so Java proklamiert und viele Informationen bietet, wer sich da nochmal installieren möchte, das ist auf jeden Fall eine der besseren Adressen, wo man hingehen kann. Steht eine Liste von offenen Servern, wo man sich einfach mal so eben einen Account machen kann, und zwar ohne, dass man irgendjemand was bezahlen muss. Die unterscheiden sich dann so ein bisschen im Wesentlichen darin, wer die betreibt, wie gut die angebunden sind, welches Featureset die haben, welche Software die einstellen. Das steht da zwar im Einzelnen nicht dabei, aber da kann man ja auch mal selber mal gucken. Im Club gab es dann auch irgendwann mal den Wunsch, eigentlich einen Java-Server aufzusetzen. Ging der Wunsch eigentlich von dir aus?
Naja, der Wunsch, der war eigentlich eher aus Frust geboren, weil es Java Berlin war, ist älter und Java Berlin hatte einfach eine Zeit lang gewisse Stabilitätsprobleme und weil da außerhalb von Berlin nicht so wirklich viel rumkam, was da eigentlich genau los ist, entstand einfach aus Frust dieses JavaCCC.de, dementsprechend ist es also wirklich auf meinem eigenen Server damals entstanden und dann so Stück für Stück größer geworden.
Wie groß ist das jetzt?
30.000 registrierte Benutzer oder so, also nicht ganz so spektakulär von absoluten Zahlen her, aber die täglichen Peaks, also der tägliche Durchschnitt maximal online, das sind zwischen 3.000 und 3.500. Also wir steuern sehr direkt auf die 3.500. Wir haben eine ziemlich deutlich steigende Tendenz, wie übrigens auch die meisten anderen Jabber-Server.
Also gut ein Sechstel ist auch wirklich die ganze Zeit aktiv.
Und auch überraschend viel mit SSL, also überraschend viel mit Krypto. Heißt auf jeden Fall, dass es zunimmt, dass die Jabber-Szene als solche erfolgreich ist. Ich meine, das ist ja kein Trend, den ich nur bei JabberCCC.de sehe. Ich habe ja mit einem ganzen Stapel anderer Server irgendwie was zu tun. Und heißt auf jeden Fall, dass wir auf einem guten Weg sind. Auch wenn natürlich die ganze Sache noch nicht perfekt ist. Das Protokoll hat noch echt hässliche Fehler streckenweise. Die Clients haben hässliche Fehler, haben vorhin schon drüber gesprochen und und und. Aber die Richtung stimmt.
Aber ist auf jeden Fall besser als jetzt bei ICQ. Ich meine, da gibt es ja auch immer wieder größere Fakaps. Vor allem, wenn sie halt immer wieder ihre Protokolle ändern. Das ist ja auch so ein beliebter Spaß bei diesen proprietären Netzen. Die bauen dann immer schon in ihre Clients so vorab Protokolländerungen ein. Und wenn sie dann sich dann halt mal wieder entscheiden, so ein paar von diesen Alternativen da draußen auf dem Markt eine harte Zeit zu bescheren, dann ändern sie halt einfach so ihr Protokoll ab. Und während der normale Client damit kein Problem hat, weil da sozusagen die Fallbacks dafür schon eingebaut sind, husten die einen natürlich erstmal und dann gibt es die entsprechenden Timeouts.
Naja, das größte Problem ist einfach, dass eben diese Protokolle alle geschlossen sind. Deswegen, du guckst dir halt ein, was kommt aus den Clients raus, was geht da wieder zurück und daraus musst du einfach raten, wie dieses Protokoll funktioniert. Wenn du dir also diese öffentlich verfügbaren Dokumentationen für ICQ z.B. anschaust, siehst du an ganz vielen Stellen Unknown, Probably, was auch immer und plötzlich ändert sich eben eines dieser Bits, plötzlich ändert sich eines, die ich bekomme schon wild gestikuliert, dass ich langsam hören soll.
Ja, ein bisschen langsamer reden.
Ja, ich weiß, Standardprobe. Es macht einfach viel zu viel Spaß bei euch.
Das ist nett, ja. Irgendwann verstehen wir dich noch nicht mehr. Also ich habe ja inhaltlich ohnehin schon immer Probleme, aber mittlerweile wird das formal auch kompliziert.
Ich kann es dir nachher noch mal in Ruhe und langsamer klären.
Wir können ja heute Nacht noch mal drüber zusammenschabbern.
Das ist ja ein Problem. Nun ja, auf jeden Fall ändert sich eben irgendetwas plötzlich an diesen unbekannten Feldern und plötzlich funktioniert nichts. Das Einzige, was weiterhin funktioniert, sind eben die offiziellen Clients von ICQ. Die haben dann wunderbare Werbung, sind ganz toll bunt und einfach schrecklich. Und all die anderen, da musst du halt warten, bis jemand auf die Idee kommt, was hat sich da geändert, warum funktioniert es nicht. Dann musst du dein Update holen und dann kannst du wieder mit ICQ kommunizieren. Das Problem hast du bei Jabber einfach nicht, weil es ein offenes, dokumentiertes, standardisiertes Protokoll ist.
Ich frage mich auch immer, wie man eigentlich... Ich habe irgendwann mal so ein paar von diesen offiziellen Clients benutzt und das war einfach gar nicht zu ertragen. Also diese Dinger, die sind so aufdringlich und dermaßen fordernd und überhaupt gar nicht benutzerfreundlich, dass es mir ehrlich gesagt ein Rätsel ist. Also ihr, alle, die ihr da noch so ICQ und so was benutzt, ich kann euch echt nur sagen, denkt mal drüber nach. Also es gibt da wirklich schöne Alternativen und man sollte wirklich mal über so einen Protokollwechsel nachdenken. Mit diesen Multi-Protokoll-Clients kann man das relativ entspannt machen, weil man kann sich halt einfach in einem neuen Netzwerk zusätzlich noch einen Account aufmachen und erweitert damit ja im Prinzip auch nochmal so seinen potenziellen Freundeskreis, weil es gibt einfach Leute, die auch nicht auf ICQ sind, so ist es ja noch auch nicht, und dann kann man eben dann so langsam durch die Gegend migrieren.
Naja, das ist ganz einfach. Die meisten Standard-Client, die laufen nur unter Windows. Dementsprechend der Durchschnitt Windows-Benutz ist schon konditioniert, einfach Patches, Updates, Veränderungen einzuspielen. Und genauso gehen die üblicherweise auch mit diesem ICQ-Client vor. Du holst ja als erst dieses furchtbar bunte Standard-Ding und dann holst du hier noch ein Tool und da noch ein Zusatzprogramm und hier und das und das. Und dann hast du so etwas wie teilweise Verschlüsselung, dann sieht es plötzlich anders aus, dann musst du noch alles konfigurieren, wie man es eben von Windows auch gewohnt ist. Wenn du nicht vorher noch die Sicherheits-Updates drüber bügelt, ist es unbenutzbar und so ähnlich geht es eben auch mit ICQ.
Naja, egal wie die Oberfläche aussieht, also irgendwann wirst du dich dran gewöhnt haben und dann fällt es dir schwer, dich wieder umzugewöhnen. Das ist ja mit allem so.
Aber jetzt erklär doch nochmal, was kommt denn auf einen zu, wenn man jetzt so einen Java-Server starten will? Ist das irgendwie ein komplizierter Vorgang oder geht das eigentlich? Ja, es ist...
Es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, da gibt es immer das Chaosradio.
Im Rahmen des Blue Moon.
Nur nicht im Dezember, da ist der Kongress heute, es ist Ordnungsnummer 119, es geht um Instant Messaging. Und Florian wollte gerade erzählen, wie es mit dem Betrieb eines Java-Servers ist.
Ja, der hat schon angefangen damit zu erzählen. Du musst dich zu allen erst mal entscheiden, was willst du überhaupt für einen Java-Server verwenden? Da draußen hat es eine ganze Menge Kleins. Die drei populärsten sind der JabberD1-4. Das hat mich jetzt gerade total von der Spur gebracht. Auf jeden Fall, es hat den JabberD1-4, es hat den E-JabberD und es hat den sogenannten Wildfire. Die haben alle Vor- und Nachteile. Also sehr populär ist E-JabberD, das basiert auf einer komischen Programmiersprache namens Alang, kommt aus dem Hause Ericsson, ist also im Mobilfunkbereich in der Industrie entwickelt worden, ist skalierbar, hat ganz, ganz viele tolle Produktmerkmale, die das durchschnittliche Nerd hat, einfach mal höher schlagen lassen. Ist aber gerade zum Debuggen her, ich komme jetzt mal sehr freundlich, gewöhnungsbedürftig, also ich mag ihn nicht, deswegen muss ich ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Was magst du nicht?
Diese E-JabberD ist super, solange er funktioniert.
Manche Software nicht, aber den magst du pro Ampere-Sprache nicht.
Beides. Also sowohl als auch, dieses Ding ist einfach super, wenn es funktioniert, am dem Moment, wenn es nicht mehr funktioniert, dann hast du einen seltsamen Zeichenhaufen und dann musst du im Prinzip die Sprache können, um zu verstehen, was dieses Teil dir mitteilen will. Das ist nicht, macht keinen Spaß und es ist wirklich eine hohe Lernschwelle. Das absolute Gegenteil ist dieser Java-basierte, dieser Wildfire, da hast du eine tolle Oberfläche, wo du alles klicken kannst, wo alles bunt ist, wo du eine tolle Dokumentation hast, weil deine Firma dahinter steht. Aber wenn du da mehr als zehn Minutzer drauf hast, dann brauchst du unglaublich viel RAM und ganz große Ressourcen. Es ist eben Java und dementsprechend musst du dir einfach überlegen, was du willst. Dieses Mittelding ist dieser JabberD1-4, das ist ganz normale C-Software, das hast du überall unter Linux, Unix, wo auch immer. Gibt es sogar für Mac OS Geschmacksache.
Weißt du, was Google verwendet?
Google hat eine komplette Eigenentwicklung. Die meisten anderen verwenden, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, E-JabberD. Also Freenet, GMX, Web.de oder auch Mabel, die verwenden durchweg E-JabberD, einfach weil das Ding sehr weit skaliert, aber auch nicht perfekt ist.
Wer übrigens was Lustiges sehen will, der soll mal bei Google Erlang the Movie eingeben. Also Erlang, die Programmiersprache, wie Erlang, bloß ohne EN am Ende, und dann einfach The Movie, der erste Link bei Google Video. Das ist eine schöne Sache. Wollte ich eigentlich schon mal bei ChaosTV posten, mir auch noch nicht zugekommen.
Ist übrigens eine sehr coole Sprache. Also von Features und so ist sie wirklich super. Deswegen, dass ich die nicht leiden kann, hat nicht unbedingt faktische Gründe.
Jaja, das ist ganz interessant. Ist so für Realtime-Programming irgendwie gedacht. Aber gut, das sind also die Softwarepakete von denen man im Prinzip machen kann. Okay, jetzt hat man die Software installiert und dann muss man sich dann irgendwo anmelden. Muss man sagen, ich bin jetzt Teil des Universums oder geht das alles auf dem Markt?
Das ist im Prinzip so wie ein E-Mail-Zwischen. Du setzt dieses Ding auf, du konfigurierst eben alles, wie es in der Dokumentation steht, wo speichere ich meine Accounts und was für Namen habe ich. Und dann legst du einfach los, dann läuft es.
Okay, dann startet der und hat erst mal keinen Benutzer. Dann komme ich an und sage, okay, super, hallo, toll. Jetzt kommt der Chaosradio-Jobber-Server und jetzt mache ich mir einen Account. Dann sagt mein Client, hallo, ich hätte gerne einen Account. Dann gebe ich mir selber ein Passwort und das schluckt er dann einfach. So, jetzt habe ich einen Account. Jetzt möchte ich aber mit Holgi sprechen und Holgi ist bei Google. Und jetzt sage ich irgendwie, la la la.
Ja, add new contact, also neuen Kontakt hinzufügen und gebe halt einfach diese Jab ID, die sieht aus wie eine E-Mail.
Genau, das heißt, der Server speichert jetzt quasi den Wunsch, mit wem er bei mir drauf sein soll. Führt er dann in dem Moment schon irgendeine Kommunikation nach außen durch?
Ja, natürlich. Also zu alles guckt er, ob er schon mit diesem anderen, er schaut, ob er mit dem anderen Server verbunden ist. Wenn nicht, dann baut er natürlich zunächst die Verbindung zu diesem Server auf und anschließend gibt es einen sogenannten Authorization-Request, also einfach die Bitte, deinen Status, deinen Online-Zustand sehen zu dürfen, wird dem Gegenüber, Tolgi, in dem Moment dann eben zugegeben.
Das heißt, ich kann nicht einfach irgendjemanden hinzufügen, sondern der muss zustimmen.
Der muss zustimmen, genau, bei Datenschutz und Privacy.
Genau, das ist ja anders als zum Beispiel bei AEM. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie bei ICQ es ist, glaube ich, ähnlich, aber bei AEM...
ICQ hängt von Clients ab. Also das ist so nicht, sie tun es eigentlich nicht, aber sie haben halt so in ihren Standard-Clients, tun sie so als ob. Aber wenn du Open Source hast, dann brauchst du keine Autorisierung.
Okay, aber bei AEM kann ich halt jeden einfach so beobachten und ich habe gar keine Kontrolle darüber, wer mich beobachtet. Das ist natürlich auch noch mal so eine Sache. Also wenn ihr AEM habt, irgendwie, you are being watched. Und bei Java kann man, muss man auf jeden Fall erstmal gefragt. Das heißt, der wird dann sozusagen gefragt, hallo irgendwie, hier der Dovezimmer aus dem Chaosradio, der möchte gerne irgendwie dir zuschauen, wie du irgendwie dein Tagwerk verrichtest. Und dann muss der irgendwie in seinem Programm erstmal sagen, okay prima, können wir zulassen. Und dann geht das wieder zurück und dann wird das erst eingetragen.
Genau, und das Ganze kann dann eben auch nur in die Gegenrichtung gehen. Also es geht nicht immer zwangsläufig in beide Richtungen gleichzeitig. Also wenn ich deinen Statue sehen darf, darfst du auch meinen und umgehen. Sondern das kann ich auch je nach Richtung unterschiedlich auswählen.
Das heißt, du kannst mir erlauben, dass ich dich sehe, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich... Und wenn ich jetzt die Kommunikation aufnehme, läuft es im Prinzip genauso. Short habe ich schon eine Verbindung zu diesem Server. Wie wissen denn jetzt die Server untereinander, dass sie auch sie sind? Also gibt es da irgendeine Authentifizierung?
Ja, das ist ein Dialback, läuft in mehreren Schritten ab.
Ein was?
Ein sogenannter Dialback nennt es das einfach in mehreren Schritten im Prinzip. Die versuchen gegenseitig, ob der Domainname, der sie vorgeben zu sind, also nein, das ist nicht ganz einfach, das ist rüber zu bringen. Du hast bei E-Mails dieses Problem, dass du Absende fälschen kannst. Also ich kann angeben, ich bin Bill at microsoft.com, so der Standardwitz und ich bin es nicht wirklich. Es gibt einfach keine Authentifizierung, weil Java hat es einfach einen Mechanismus, der eben sicherstellt, dass der Server tatsächlich diesen Domainnamen besitzt. Und dementsprechend geht es in ein paar mehr Schritten, dass in beide Richtungen einfach klar ist, dass da kein Blödsinn passiert.
Mit anderen Worten, es ist eigentlich ein relativ robustes System und man kann sich schon doch relativ sicher sein, dass die Person, die da jetzt mit einem kommuniziert, oder zumindest der Account, der da mit einem kommuniziert, auch tatsächlich daherkommt, von wo man so den Eindruck hat, dass man sich in der Zeit relativ viel erkocht. Ich sag mal, wer ist eigentlich Dunbar? Dunbar.
Ich hab nicht die leisteste Ahnung, wieso?
Robin Dunbar. Ist eine Anthropologe. Wie komm ich da drauf? Ich komm da drauf, weil wir ja eine tolle Mitmachseite haben beim Chaosradio unter wiki, chaosradio.cc.de gibt's zu Chaosradio und allen unseren Sendungen. Dann auch immer zu jeder Sendung eine sogenannte Mitmachseite. Da steht viel über die Sendungen drin und das wenigste davon ist von uns. Das heißt, vor der Sendung landen dort die Fragen und während der Sendung vielleicht dort auch die Antworten. Und das ist auf jeden Fall für uns auch immer eine gute Quelle, die Sendung inhaltlich zu gestalten. Insofern bedanken wir uns da auch mal immer wieder für die große Aktivität, die dort entfacht wird. Diesmal sind relativ viele Fragen hier gelandet.
Und auch viele E-Mails.
Und viele E-Mails sind noch dazu. Aber ich dachte, ich schau mal hier zumindest erst mal hier rein. Das ist mir zu lang. Okay, aber warum ich darauf gekommen bin mit Herrn Dunbar? Also Herr Dunbar hat postuliert, dass man keine stabilen sozialen Beziehungen zu mehr als 150 Menschen führen kann. Hast du davon schon mal gehört, FH?
Naja, die Nummer gibt es tatsächlich. Die ist auch umstritten. Aber da ist auch erst die Frage, wie siehst du stabile soziale Beziehungen? Ich meine, die Frage geht es darauf hin, wie viele Leute hast du in deinem Roaster? Also wie viele habe ich in meiner Kontaktliste? Das sind bei mir deutlich mehr als 300. Aber da würde ich vielleicht 20 Prozent als echte soziale Kontakte bezeichnen. Der Rest sind halt einfach so die Klassiker, die auf JabberCCC die mal ankamen und irgendwas wissen wollten. Was zum Glück übrigens alles inzwischen Peter, der Kollege sozusagen, übernimmt, der macht inzwischen die Hauptarbeit bei der Administration. Und dementsprechend inzwischen kriegt er die ganzen nervigen Fragen ab.
Gut, die eigentliche Frage, die hier dahinter steht, ist, wie managt ihr eure Kontakte? Und da muss ich sagen, ich finde das ja auch sehr gut mit dieser, bei Java kann man halt so schön immer erst mal, erst mal müssen die Leute ja anklopfen. Also bevor die sich nicht irgendwie sagen mit Hallo, naja sagen nicht, wer sie sind, aber sie müssen auf jeden Fall von mir erst mal zugelassen werden und dann kommt sie bei mir erst mal so auf so eine Qualifikationsgruppe und dann schaue ich halt mal, was sie eigentlich so von mir wollen und wenn sie, was weiß ich, nur quasi mich auf Beobachtung gesetzt haben, dann fliegen sie halt auch irgendwann wieder raus.
Was die meisten benutzen, aber dann total emotional sehen, finde ich richtig witzig. Also wenn ich dann die Leute, wenn du wieder anfängst, die zu entsorgen, weil von denen hast du seit einem Dreiviertel nie gehört, du hast eh keine Ahnung, wer das ist, also wirfst sie dir weg, dann bekommen die das teilweise in ihren Clients mitgeteilt, dass du jetzt also diese Berechtigung, den Status zu sehen, wie du entzogen hast.
Hallo, FH kann dich nicht mehr leiden.
Genau, genau, die nehmen das total persönlich, was natürlich nicht persönlich gemeint ist, aber ich meine, gerade wenn ich mit UMTS unterwegs bin, dann kostet das einfach Zeit, weil das wird ja jedes Mal beim Login alles übertragen und es interessiert mich nicht so brutal, dass es klingt.
Und machst du nun das Holger?
Ich habe so viele Kontakte nicht, ich lasse sie einfach alle stehen. Also ich mache kein 300.
Du akzeptierst auch jeden.
Na ja, wer sollte mich groß ansprechen? Also ich meine, die Leute müssen ja auch erst mal wissen, wie ich heiße.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn du jetzt deine Jabber-ID promotest, ich bin mir sicher, dass es spontan sehr viel mehr wird.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Neue Freunde?
Neue Freunde unter holgejabber.ccc.de. Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert. Wahrscheinlich geht jetzt dieser Mabber, hier passiert gar nichts.
Du bist doch der Mann mit 38 Millionen In-Mail-Adressen. Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Ich muss das irgendwie ein bisschen kanalisieren. Ich muss das eben irgendwie kanalisieren.
Du bist gar nicht Holge jetzt, aber...
Ich sagte Holgie, Holgie wäre schön, aber das war schon irgendwie weg.
Das ist der Gemur, das ist nicht du.
Kannst du den nicht mal rausadministrieren?
Wer Holger als Freund haben will, abonniert Holgie.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie hier euer Mabba-Dings, was ich ja wirklich... Da würde ich auch ganz gerne noch mal Werbung für machen. Also dir ist das ja ein bisschen peinlich, Eva.
Na ja, was heißt peinlich?
Weil du da arbeitest.
Ja, es riecht seltsam, wenn ich in der Sendung bin.
Bei mir riecht es nicht seltsam. Ich bin nicht bezahlt worden. Ich leide auch eher unter diesen Mabagerdöns. Das ist, erklär nochmal genau, was das ist. Also ich finde es ganz praktisch. Es ist HTML-basiert, ein Jabber-Client, der ganz viele Gateways hat, sodass ich auf IAM, ICQ und sonst wie was kontakte.
Es sind drei Dinge. Es sind drei Dinge. Es ist erstens, wie du schon sagtest, so ein web-basierter Client. Also ich kann immer im Browser direkt Jabber bedienen und ich brauche auch keine extra Ports oder so. Es geht durch die meisten Firmen Firewalls durch oder Schulfirewalls oder wo auch immer. Dann ist es ein Handy-Client, dass ich also übers Handy online gehen kann, was je nachdem, was ich für einen Vertrag mit meinem Provider habe, deutlich billiger als SMS ist pro Nachricht und dann eben die eigentliche Jabber-Infrastruktur mit den Gateways und und und unterscheidet einen auch von vielen anderen. Es ist noch beta, deswegen hat es noch ein paar Probleme. Die Probleme sind bekannt, wir arbeiten auch dran.
Ich hoffe, ihr arbeitet vor allen Dingen an den Problemen mit dem Handy-Client. Also da kann ich ja wirklich, also ich möchte ja heulen.
Ja, ich habe schon interessante neue Sachen gesehen. Es wird alles besser und ich glaube, mein Chef wäre auch total stolz auf mich, wenn ich jetzt erzählen würde, dass wir noch mehr Jobs anzubieten haben, aber ich will hier keine Baubung machen.
Was, ihr habt Jobs anzubieten?
Ja, natürlich.
Auf diese Leute wie mich.
Also ich meine, der interessante Punkt, der einzige interessante Punkt jetzt, ist der, dass natürlich alle Leute das auch auf ihrem mobilen Gerät, also auf dem Telefon, haben wollen. Weil schlicht und ergreifend, es wird nach dem Ersatz für SMS gesucht. SMS ist einfach zu teuer. Das sind einfach die teuersten Bits auf diesem Planeten, gerade hier in Deutschland. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wenn ich irgendwie 160 Zeichen schicken kann, das macht ja in der Regel keiner. Man hat vielleicht 20 Zeichen, Nachrichten, dazu hat man 20 Cent, das ist einfach 1 Cent pro Buchstabe. Wenn man Webseiten für diesen Preis beitragen würde, wären alle Leute sofort nach 5 Klicks total arm. So geht das nicht weiter. Und die ersten Möglichkeiten, das zu umgehen, gibt es auch. Das eine ist halt solche kleinen Programme, die man immer auf dem Handy installiert.
Hat es übrigens auch schicke Open-Source-Programme, also nicht, dass es jetzt überhaupt noch kommt.
Wie heißt denn das Teil?
Mein absoluter Lieblingsclient heißt Bombus. Also B-O-M-B-U-S. Nicht erschrecken, die Website ist nur russisch, da sind nur kürrliche Buchstaben. Aber man kann sich bis zum Download-Link durchklicken und danach ist der Client selbst auch englisch. Ein Problem hat er halt mit SSL, weil die meisten Handys nur die Zertifikate akzeptieren, die sie schon bezahlterweise kennen. Aber ansonsten ist das Ding einfach genial. Ich bin absoluter Fan davon, ich habe auch schon in meinem Blog drüber geschrieben. Super, auf jeden Fall. Da müsste ich nachschauen. Das ist irgendwie ganz weder URL. Schau in meinem Blog, das müsste eines der letzten Einträge sein.
In deinem?
Natürlich, auch ich blogge. Es war selten und langweilig, aber ich blogge.
Das ist gar nicht so langweilig.
Doch, es ist auf einmal kaputt und ich weiß, dass da alles kaputt ist. Ich brauche also keine Bugreports. Auf jeden Fall war es auch ganz interessant, es gibt da auch einen eigenen Standard von den Handyhersteller. Das ist in dem Fall, Nokia, Sony Ericsson und Siemens. Siemens bin ich mir nicht sicher, die anderen beiden bin ich mir sicher. Das ist der Standard, der heißt IMPS, also EMPS. Und das ist dann direkt Instant Messaging fürs Handy. Das können die meisten modernen Handys, dürfen es aber einfach im Menü noch nicht anbieten, weil es eine Konkurrenz zu SMS ist. Aber wenn du ein ungebrandetes Handy hast, dann funktioniert das bereits. Und das ist dann direkt nativ ins Handy eingebaut und ist genau darauf optimiert.
Hat das irgendwas mit Jabber zu tun?
Es ist so ähnlich. Wenn du dir die Protokollspezifikationen anschaust, siehst du, dass es sehr ähnlich zu Jabber ist, plus die Features, die du als Mobilfunkanbieter haben willst, die einfach alle was mit bezahlen zu tun haben. Also, der kann so verschiedene Fehlermeldungen, die Jabber einfach nicht kann, wie du dürftest das jetzt sehen, aber dazu müsstest du erst bezahlen und solche Dinge. Das hat Jabber natürlich erst mal nicht. Aber es ist sehr ähnlich.
Das klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie WAP. Ja, das ist so wie erfinden, dass irgendwie das alles nochmal neu ist, das das Internet schon längst etabliert hat und machen die Bezahlknopf drauf.
In erster Linie stecken einfach eine ganze Tonne Patente mit drin, weil es ist dann alles so komisches Binary, XML und komprimiert und Zeug und da steckt eine Patente. Man will es nicht unbedingt benutzen, aber ich wollte es nur erwähnt haben, der Vollständigkeit halber. Und es können verdammt viele Handys tatsächlich schon.
Also dieser Bombos-Kline, den du erwähnt hast, worauf läuft denn der eigentlich?
J2MI, also Java auf Handys, ganz normal.
Okay, also wahrscheinlich auf sehr vielen Telefonen. Und da ist in der Tat alles schön kyrillisch, mit Versionsnummern und vielleicht habt ihr ja Erfolg.
Und verstehst du jetzt, warum ich mir die Domain nicht merken konnte?
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Ich schmeiße jetzt mal einen direkten Download-Link ins fritz.de.
Das ist ja heftig.
Nicht gut?
Fritzbord klingt toll.
Fritzbord klingt toll, ich weiß nur nicht wohin. Blue Moon, da ist es hübsch. Und dann kommst du wieder. Blue Moon, achso, da muss ich mich erst anmelden. Erzählt mal was, ich mache hier gerade Dienstleistungen am Kundendienst.
Erzählen, ich könnte ja einfach langsamer sprechen. Ich bin ja schon wieder von unserem treuen Hörergatt darauf hingewiesen worden, dass ich langsamer sprechen soll.
Mir ist übrigens eben die Autorisierung, oder wie es heißt, entzogen worden.
Das wollte ich nicht mehr sagen.
Du durftest hier nicht mehr, alle hatten immer um die Ecke.
Gut, worauf ich ja persönlich setze, das sind Erträgliche Geräte mit normalen Java-Klines, die dann Nutzen davon ziehen, dass man immer am Internet ist. Für UMTS, das tolle neue Netz. Es gibt ja mittlerweile halbwegs brauchbare Flatwires, also nicht nur für UMTS, sondern auch für GPRS, was ja eigentlich auch ausreicht für Java, wenn man nicht zu viele Leute hat, mit denen man kommuniziert. Da zahlt man halt auch nur echt für jedes Byte, beziehungsweise bei einer Flatrate halt gar nicht. Das ist eigentlich die ideale Voraussetzung. Anders als bei SMS, also man zahlt nicht für jedes Byte, das wollte ich sagen. Bei SMS zahlt man halt wirklich für jede Nachricht, immer wieder, und egal, wie viel man überträgt, hat man halt bei Java den Vorteil, entweder man zahlt nur für das, was man überträgt, oder im Idealfall bei einer Flatrate eben sowieso nur Pauschal ist. Und dadurch wird das auf einmal billig. Und dadurch wird das auf einmal auch ganz anders, weil man muss nicht jedes Mal darüber nachdenken, oh, kann ich mir das jetzt leisten? ZB die Leute, die das eh nicht tun, die kommen dann nicht in die böse Kostenfallerei.
Und vor allem, du hast natürlich durch dieses offene Protokoll ganz schicke zusätzliche Ideen. Du könntest zum Beispiel auf die Idee kommen, viele moderne Handys haben GPS-Empfänger, dass du einfach den aktuellen Standard, wo du dich befindest, irgendwie mit publizierst. Und, und, und, also, du kannst dadurch, dass es eben offen ist, jede Menge neue Features implementieren. Auf neue Ideen kommen gerade, die eben erst dadurch, dass du mobil bist, interessant werden. Genau.
So, der Link ist jetzt auch da. fritz.de, fritzbord, bluemoon, bombus.
Ich werde dir gerade gefragt, warum du das nicht gleich ins Wiki schreibst, Spalter.
Wo ist es denn noch?
wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de und dann gleich so ein prominenter Link, der da immer auf der Homepage gepflegt wird, auf den aktuellen Klimpen. Aber wahrscheinlich steht es da eh schon drin, ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher. Aber das wäre natürlich das wünschenswerte Forum, wo wir alle irgendwie hinbringen möchten. Vielleicht noch ein letztes Wort zu Java, wo sich Java eben auch unterscheidet von den anderen Diensten und wo man auch wirklich einen Vorteil davon hat, dass man hier ein anderes Protokoll benutzt, weil häufig ist es ja sozusagen nur die Replikation von den gleichen und dasselbe im Grün. Was mit Java auch geht, ist, dass man mit mehreren Computern gleichzeitig online ist. Multiple Clients nennt man das? Benutzst du das?
Ja, natürlich.
Und wie?
Indem ich einfach zum Beispiel mit meinem Laptop daheim am Schreibtisch dauerhaft online bin und dann, wenn ich mit meinem Handy online gehe, zusätzlich. Und ich kann eine sogenannte Priority, eine Priorität vergeben. Also ich kann einfach sagen, wenn ich mit meinem Handy online bin, ist das wichtiger. Deswegen möchte ich, dass da alle Nachrichten kommen. Ansonsten ist das wichtigste, mein Laptop bitte dorthin schicken. Und dementsprechend kann ich mit fast beliebig vielen Clients online sein. Und ich kann viele sogar schon, also in Fundsteuern darüber, was dann soweit geht. Wenn ich an die Uni gehe, ich mache da irgendeinen Rechner an, ich stelle fest, ich habe daheim vergessen, meinen Jabberclient auszumachen, dann kann ich einfach diesen Jabberclient bei mir daheim sagen, gib mir doch bitte alle Nachrichten, die in der Zwischenzeit bei dir aufgelaufen sind und anschließend gehe offline.
Super, dann sagen wir mal, in der Uhrzeit der Computergeschichte, ich weiß noch, damals, als ich irgendwie in der Notwendigkeit war, zu rechtfertigen, warum ich denn unbedingt einen Computer haben wollte.
Alle haben einen.
Damals hatte ja keiner einen.
Ja stimmt, Mist.
Ja, das hat nicht gezogen so, ja. Ja, und dann kommt man dann irgendwann auf die Sache mit dem automatischen Blumen gießen. Und mit Java wäre das jetzt auch mal wieder eine tolle Ausrede, dass man daheim so einen Rechner hat, wo man irgendwie immer, wenn man den Java-Message gießt, jetzt mal die Blumen schickt, dass er dann auch tatsächlich die Blumen gibt.
Ja genau, und wenn die Blume auf der Boi geht, weißt du, sie fängt an zu waken.
Ja, aber da sprichst du ein schönes Ding an. Java ist eigentlich auch ein optimales Tool für alle Formen von Automatisierung. Es gibt ja zahlreiche Erweiterungen, die sogenannten Java Extensions.
Genau, die übrigens gerade unbenannt wurden. Ach ja, naja, es ist open source, da ist ganz wichtig, was drauf steht. Und wir haben ja auf der einen Seite den Namen Java und auf der anderen Seite den Namen XMPP. Das eine ist ein Trademark in den USA, das andere ist eine tolle Abkürzung, deswegen geben wir es alle zur tollen Abkürzung, die kein Trademark ist. Das heißt jetzt XEP statt JEP. Also es sind jetzt halt XMPP Enhancement Proposals. Und das geht jetzt so Stück für Stück. Es ist eigentlich vollkommen albern, aber sie finden es schick.
Okay, das ist ja auch eine nachvollziehbare Geschichte. Java ist halt so der Slang und XMPP ist die Abkürzung, die sich keiner merken kann.
Sie wollen auch beides beibehalten, aber halt so ein bisschen die technische Schiene von der sozialen Schiene trennen, einfach.
Verständlich. Ja, aber wie kann man jetzt diese Erweiterungen, also was gibt es denn da so? Was ist denn da so der Ausblick in dieser Erweiterungslandschaft, was das Protokoll jetzt noch lastig ist?
Na ja, es sind einfach, erstens, jeder kann solche Erweiterungen einreichen. Das geht an einen ganz normalen, spellanatisierten Prozess. Viele Leute gucken durch, stimmen darüber ab, ob das tatsächlich eine Erweiterung wird. Und es ist, wie der Name schon sagt, einfach eine Protokollerweiterung. Also etwas, was ich implementieren kann, aber nicht muss. Und alle möglichen verschiedenen Dienstmarkte.
Aber was gibt es denn da?
Zum Beispiel 190. Du hast zum Beispiel ganz populär.
Einer reicht.
Ja, genau, PubSub. Das ist jetzt eigentlich erst mal technisch und eine furchtbare Abkürzung, nennt sich einfach Publish Subscribe.
Also abonnieren und veröffentlichen und abonnieren.
Viel interessanter, viel deutlicher, was der Sinn dahinter ist, sieht man einfach, wenn man ein Beispiel nennt. Nämlich nehmen wir RSS Blogs lesen oder anyes. Das sind diese RSS-Feeds, wo ich einfach mit einem entsprechenden Reader mitbekommen kann, es hat sich was geändert. Dazu muss ich alle 30 Minuten, alle 2 Stunden, im regelmäßigen Intervall nachschauen, hat sich was geändert, wenn sich was geändert hat, bekomme ich dann eben die neuen Einträge. Mit PubSub kann ich das im Prinzip genauso machen, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass wenn ich jetzt der Block anbiete, ich habe also ein RSS-Feed, dann biete ich einen sogenannten PubSub-Note an, in der all diese Informationen gespeichert sind. Und wenn jemand jetzt diesen Feed lesen will, wenn jemand wissen will, was ich bekomme, dann meldet er sich bei dem Note an und sagt, hey, gib mir Bescheid, sobald es Updates gibt. Und in dem Moment bekommst du sofort, also in dem Moment, wenn die neue Nachricht online kommt, bekommst du sofort Bescheid und du musst eben nicht regelmäßig nachfragen, sondern nur genau dieses eine Mal. Das spart alles den Traffic und es ist schneller.
Mit einigen Worten, man muss nicht die ganze Zeit an die Tür klopfen und fragen, ob sich irgendwas geändert hat, sondern die Tür öffnet sich von alleine und sagt, hurra, guten Tag. Es gibt mal wieder Dinge, die dich vielleicht interessieren könnten.
Jetzt höre ich auf zu telefonieren und schreibe alles, was ich mitzuteilen habe, in ein kleines Fensterchen. Drücke auf einen Knopf, schick das durch eine Leitung und keiner liest mit.
Das ist der Vorteil von Instant Messaging, dass du nicht mitlesen musst.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist doch schon eine relativ paranoide Veranstaltung, oder? Also insbesondere die proprietären Sachen. Also von ICQ wird ja immer wieder gesagt, dass da der Mossad dahinter stecken würde.
Nein, nein, nein, schon länger nicht mehr. Genau, die Geschichte ist verständlich, wo sie herkommt. Sie kommt nicht einfach daher, dass ICQ von einer israelischen Firma entwickelt wurde. Und im Zuge dessen kam natürlich, wenn Israel draufsteht, glaubt jeder, der Mossad steckt drin. Und das ist jetzt aber an AOL, Time Warner, verkauft worden. Deswegen sitzt es in den USA. Inwieweit ist es besser oder schlechter als der Mossad? Was da jetzt dahinter sitzen kann, kann man sich streiten. Aber die Mossad-Legende ist nicht mehr ganz up to date. Nein.
Nee, das, also was weiß man schon, aber das ist eigentlich so ein typisches Start-up gewesen. Die Jungs, die das in Israel gemacht haben, das ICQ, die Vardy Brothers, das ist da so eine Familie von, die sind da alle irgendwie ganz savvy und Papa hat es dann irgendwann verkauft.
Das klingt ein bisschen wie die Yamba-Brüder hier.
Seitdem sind sie alle...
Haben sie keine Freunde mehr, sind aber stinkreich.
Sie sind aber sehr nett. Also ich habe die mal kennengelernt. Nein, die Vardys, die also diesen ICQ-Kram verbrochen haben. Die sind da sehr angesehene Geschäftsleute und sehr juviale und freundliche Menschen. Das war eine sehr angenehme Bekanntschaft.
Also davon muss ich keine Angst haben. Wovor muss ich denn Angst haben?
Naja, wovor man einfach Angst muss man sowieso nicht haben. Sollte man sowieso nicht haben. Aber man sollte sich einfach bewusst sein, was man tut, wenn man jetzt über ICQ, AEM, MSN, was auch immer chattet. Es gibt da einen, beziehungsweise technisch sind es natürlich viele Server, aber im Prinzip fungiert das alles wie ein einziger Server. Ich rede mit anderen Leuten, alles was ich tippe geht in den allermeisten Fällen unverschlüsselt durch und vor allem hat man eben auch komplette soziale Netzwerke. Man braucht sich ja einfach nur anschauen, wer hat wen auf seiner Liste. Ja, das ist das ist etwas, was man bei vielen anderen Netzen, bei Telefonnetzwerkanalysen, bei Trafikanalysen, das ist genau das, was die Software-Programme, die dann über diese Log-Dateien hermachen, herausfinden wollen. Also nicht die typische Forschung auf Telefondaten, warum die Regierungen das immer speichern wollen, ist ja, um herauszufinden, wer ist eigentlich mit wem zu Gange, wer ist wessen Freund, wer hat mit wem am meisten Kommunikation. Und bei Instant Messaging liefert man diese Daten frei Haus. Man hat genau irgendwie seine Freunde mit drauf und mit der einzelnen Kommunikation wird also ganz klar kommuniziert, jetzt rede ich mit dem und zwar genau so viele Bites. Also selbst, wenn es verschlüsselt ist, kriegt man eben bis zu einem bestimmten Maße auch noch ganz gut mit, was da abgeht im Sinne von wer mit wem, wann wie häufig und so weiter. Und daraus kann man schon eine ganze Menge Schlüssel ziehen. Es gibt es natürlich immer wieder diesen Klassiker, ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen, das glaube ich eben keim. Also wir haben alle eine ganze Menge zu verbergen. Und selbst wenn man nichts zu verbergen hätte, kann einem immer noch eine ganze Menge unterstellt werden. Und so bewegen wir uns natürlich bei Instant Messaging wirklich in einem sehr kritischen Feld. Und dessen muss man sich klar sein. Von daher sollte man seine Werkzeuge so wählen und seine Server auch so wählen, dass man von vornherein schon mal viel ausschließt.
Genau, vor allem sollte man sich eben klar sein, dass die meisten Proprietärmessenger wie im ICQ vollkommen unverschlüsselt auch in der Verbindung sind. Also selbst wenn man davon ausgeht, dass AOL, Yahoo und Microsoft die Guten sind und prinzipiell nichts Böses machen würden, kann immer noch der Admin von nebenan oder aus dem Keller auch die Daten mitlesen, wenn er Zugriff auf einen Rechner unterwegs hat. Und der hat ja wirklich dann umstände Interesse. Und sei es auch nur, weil er herausfinden will, ob du gerade eine Freundin hast oder nicht. Und dementsprechend, da hat es auch sehr konkrete Bedrohungsszenarien selbst, wenn du jetzt nicht auf Paranoia gegenüber Großkonzernen stehst.
Ich bin so vor ein paar Monaten bei AIM einfach mal so rausgefallen. Mein Account hat einfach nicht mehr funktioniert. Ich war mir relativ sicher, ich habe keinerlei Passwortänderungen vorgenommen oder so. Kann ja sein, dass jemand anderes für mich vorgenommen hat, weil bei AIM ist halt auch die Passwortübertragung nicht so verschlüsselt, wie man das haben möchte. Kann ich nicht ausschließen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es halt meinen Account noch. Bloß absurderweise konnte ich halt auch nicht über das Webinterface dafür sorgen, dass mir ein neues Passwort zugeschickt wird. Diese Funktion gibt es ja eigentlich. Gut, dachte ich mir so. Dann hat der Hijacker wahrscheinlich auch schon die gespeicherte E-Mail-Adresse dahinter verändert, aber dem war nicht so, denn ich bekomme die Werbung nach wie vor.
Was ich manchmal habe, ist, dass mein...
aber es ist alles total fischig und das große Problem ist, bei AIM, die haben Millionen Kunden, ich erreichte einfach kein. Das wäre auch einfach zu teuer.
Ich meine, das müssten sie ja dann irgendwo refinanzieren, wenn du Support machst.
Genau, da lobe ich mir so meine Java-CTC-DE und vergleichbaren Infrastrukturen, wo man noch seinen Admin irgendwie in der Kneipe trifft und ich glaube, das ist eine ganz hilfreiche Sache, man sollte einfach dafür sorgen, dass die Leute, die für einen die kritische Infrastruktur betreuen, dass man zu denen irgendeinen Bezug hat. Das muss jetzt nicht eine persönliche Bekanntschaft sein, aber zumindest, dass man weiß, wer es ist oder wie man die erreichen kann und dass die auch in der Regel auf solche Anfragen reagieren. Denn es geht dann häufig auch um verlorene Kommunikation. Man verlässt sich ja auch auf solche Systeme, wenn heute mal ein Instant Messaging kaputtgeht und ich habe jetzt die nächsten zwei Monate keine Möglichkeit, das aufzunehmen. Das dauert vielleicht lange, das wieder neu aufzubauen und vor allem das zu kommunizieren, dass man vielleicht eine andere Adresse hat oder so was. Und das muss man natürlich dabei auch berücksichtigen.
Und vor allem jetzt, wo du sagen, was mir öfter mal passiert, ist, dass Adium, also mein Client meldet, ich sei an zwei Stellen gleichzeitig eingeloggt, obwohl ich das garantiert nicht bin. Das ist auch ganz interessant.
Das kann aber so mit so hängenden Verbindungen zu tun haben, wenn so der eigene DSL-Router sich mal ausschaltet und wieder hoch wählt und dann eine neue IP-Adresse bekommt und dann lockt er sich wieder ein und das andere gilt noch. Also das klingt zwar beunruhigend, aber ist wahrscheinlich jetzt gar nicht so beunruhigend.
Und ich dachte, ich wäre eine Verschwörung auf der Spur.
An einem fernen Ort mitten in den österreichischen Alpen, dort wo sich Schneefuchs und Skihase, ey was geht alter sagen, wartet eines der modernsten Wintersport-Hotels Europas auf euch. Die Cube Wintersport Homebase. Und Fritz bringt euch genau dahin. Snowboard, Ski und jede Menge Spaß im Schnee, da wo es im kältesten Winter am heißesten hergeht. Fritz bringt euch in die Cube Wintersport Homebase. In der Skiregion Nassfeld-Hermagor in Kärnten. Ein Hotel wie ein Raumschiff. Gelandet in einem der besten Wintersportgebiete Europas. Das ultimative Wintersportvergnügen. Eine Reise, vier Tage, 50 Plätze. Mit Fritz zum Winterspaß ins Alpenheim. Und wie kommt man damit?
mehrinfos.fritz.de Und ab kommenden Montag auf allen Frequenzen von...
Die Bundesagentur für Arbeit gibt heute in Nürnberg die Arbeitsmarktdaten für November bekannt. Experten gehen davon aus, dass sich die positive Entwicklung der vergangenen Monate fortgesetzt hat. Nach Informationen der Hannoverischen Allgemeinen Zeitung ist die Zahl der Erwerbslosen im November gegenüber dem Vormonat um mehr als 100.000 auf unter 4 Millionen gesunken. Im Oktober waren noch 4.085.000 Menschen arbeitslos gemeldet. Das Bundeskabinett hat die Rente mit 67 beschlossen. Der Gesetzentwurf zur Alterssicherung sieht die schrittweise Anhebung des Rentenalters von 65 auf 67 Jahre zwischen den Jahren 2012 und 2029 vor. Damit verbunden ist eine Beschäftigungsinitiative für Ältere. Langjährige Versicherte, die mindestens 45 Jahre Beiträge gezahlt haben, sollen weiterhin mit 65 Jahren abschlagsfreien Rente gehen können. Noch vor Weihnachten soll der Entwurf in erster Lesung im Bundestag beraten werden. Bei den Ermittlungen um den Tod des Kreml-Kritikers Litvinenko sind nun auch an Bord von Passagierflugzeugen der Fluggesellschaft British Airways Spuren einer radioaktiven Substanz entdeckt worden. Die betroffenen drei Maschinen waren laut British Airways auf der Strecke London-Moscow im Einsatz. Nach Informationen der BBC handelt es sich bei der gefundenen Substanz um Polonium 2x10. Litvinenko war mit dieser Substanz vergiftet worden. Zum Sport. Die Basketballer von Alver Berlin haben im Julep Cup die erste Heimniederlage hinnehmen müssen. Der deutsche Vizemeister verlor gegen Harpoel Jerusalemets 77 zu 92. Im Fußball UEFA Pokal unterlag Bayer Leverkusen am vierten Spieltag der Gruppe B bei Dynamo Bukarest mit 1 zu 2. Heute Nacht lockert es von Westen her auf. Dazu gibt es Tiefstwerte von 7 bis 3 Grad. Der Tag beginnt stellenweise mit Nebel. Später dann ist es wolkig, ab und zu auch mal sonnig. Bei 7 bis 9 Grad. A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Frankfurt-Oder. Zwischen Frankfurt-Oder West und Frankfurt-Oder Mitte gab es einen Unfall. Dort ist die Autobahn gesperrt. A12 Frankfurt-Oder Richtung Berliner Ring. Zwischen Frankfurt-Oder Mitte und Frankfurt-Oder West ist die linke Fahrspur wegen Bergungsarbeiten gesperrt. A19 Rostock Richtung Wittstock-Dosse. Und A24 Schwerin Richtung Berliner Ring. Hier kommt es stellenweise zu Sichtbehinderungen durch Nebel. Fahrt also entsprechend vorsichtig. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Mario. Gleich sechs Minuten nach halb eins.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder.
Tja, wir sind ja im Chat noch mal aufgefordert worden, aber beim Versuch die Liste der unbestechlichen Politiker Deutschlands abzusuchen, ist leider heuliges Computer abgestürzt.
Genau.
Deswegen können wir diese Liste hier leider noch nicht veröffentlichen.
Da passieren ganz komische Sachen.
Also nicht abgestürzt, sondern nur massive CPU-Laste.
Ja genau, man sucht gerade und ist so.
Ich glaub, muss doch irgendeiner in die Landtag.
Du hast da überhaupt zu viel rumgespielt.
Ne, das macht Lotus. Also wir benutzen hier aus irgendwelchen Gründen Lotus. Notes, um E-Mails hinunter zu schicken. Also wir schießen mit Kanonen auf Spatzen. Und das friert irgendwie. Die da auf zerplatzen, genau. Und irgendwann zwischen 0 Uhr und 1 Uhr, also immer so kurz nach Mitternacht fängt das an, völlig rum zu baggen. Ja, und sämtliche Rechner, auf denen es gerade zufälligerweise läuft, frieren ein und verhalten sich ganz seltsam. Das ist etwas unangenehm immer.
Na ja, vielleicht hört ihr eure Techniker gerade zu, dann kann er sich ja mal drum kümmern.
Naja, das muss ja dann wieder mit Anträgen und drei Durchschlägen und so.
Klingt so nach täglichen Wartungsarbeiten, die so automatisch durch die Uhr zeitlos getreten werden. Überlast und so. Tja, also von daher können wir diese Liste nicht veröffentlichen. Schade.
Aber wenn wir es getan hätten, wir euch ohnehin hinterher sofort erschießen müssen auch.
Ja, wir waren jetzt hier gerade so ein bisschen bei der Vertrauensfrage.
Die hat ein Kanzler auch schon mal gestellt.
Deswegen benutzen ja auch viele Leute zum Beispiel gerne Skype. Skype ist so eine Sache, tja, das kann man so und kann man so sehen. Also zunächst einmal ist Skype nicht unbedingt gerade populär, weil es jetzt für Instant Messaging so die erste Wahl ist, sondern Skype ist vor allem populär, weil es so für Internet, Telefonie prima funktioniert. Vor allem, weil es halt durch alle Netzwerkkonfigurationen durchkommt. Das ist meine Erfahrung. Also man startet das und es gibt einfach mal selten Stress, während alle anderen Telefonietools, egal ob die nun auf Standards basieren oder noch mal eine eigene Lösung für irgendwas haben. Das ist alles braun und blöd und funktioniert dann bestenfalls in 90% der Fälle. Das ist irgendwie für ein Telefon einfach zu wenig. Da ist man zu viel gewohnt von normalen Telefonen. Und ein Feature, was halt Skype mit daherbringt, ist, dass eben alles verschlüsselt ist von vornherein. Das klingt natürlich zunächst einmal toll, hat aber das Problem, dass Skype eine vollständige proprietäre Geschichte ist und dass eben niemand genau weiß, wie diese Verschlüsselung tatsächlich funktioniert. Da ist zwar so einiges reingeniert worden. Ich weiß nicht, wie tief das so ging. Im Einzelnen nur ist es natürlich eine Verschlüsselung, von der man nicht weiß, wie sie funktioniert. Immer so eine Sache.
Naja, die Security bei Obscurity, also Sicherheit durch nicht transparent machen, wie gut das funktioniert, hat der Klubs letztes Mal bei den Wahlcomputern gezeigt, wo es ja genau so funktioniert hat.
Das ist das erste Mal bei den Telefonkarten oder wo war das?
Ja, am laufenden Meter, also das funktioniert nicht. Das ist halt einfach doof. Wobei, man muss schon sagen, das sind jetzt auch keine Anfänger. Die Leute, die Skype gemacht haben, das sind die Schaffer des Kazaar Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerks. Und einiges der Erfahrungen sind da wohl auch mit reingeflossen. Also auch so ein Skype Client ist eigentlich so eine Peer-to-Peer-Software. Das heißt, man leitet auch gleichzeitig Daten für andere Telefongespräche mit durch, wenn der eigene Netzwerkzugang das zulässt. Und naja, wie gesagt, funktioniert ganz gut. Und da ist halt auch noch Instant Messaging mit drin. Während jetzt solche Sachen wie Google Talk es eigentlich eher andersrum machen. Es sind halt eigentlich Programme, die Instant Messaging-Technologie implementieren vor allem und dann eben auch noch die Möglichkeit haben, Audio-Verbindung oder Video-Verbindung dann später wohl auch noch hinzuzufügen. iChat macht das genauso. Auch AIM hat ja Videotelefonie mit drin. Und überhaupt ist Telefonie das große Thema. Da ist sich halt immer noch so um das, die die goldene Kuh handelt, schlechthin. Also man kann damit einfach immer noch sehr viel Geld verdienen. Und die Märkte wollen sie natürlich alle haben. Und deswegen wird auch mit harten Bandagen gekämpft. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein Grund, warum auch kostenlose IEM-Dienste also mit angeboten werden. Weil die Leute erhalten sich damit natürlich riesige Communities, die man so peu à peu dann eben die Features machen kann.
Wir haben einen Anrufer. Das wird noch eine Verschlüsselung.
Und zwar hat er gesagt, dass die ganze Instant-Messaging-Geschichte, dass das zu 90% unverschlüsselt übertragen wird. Ich hatte mich irgendwann mal für Trillian entschieden, weil nicht alle Leute ICQ hatten, die ich kannte. Trillian bietet ja meistens auch an, verschlüsselte Sitzungen zu machen. Würde mich mal interessieren, wie man dieser Verschlüsselung trauen kann oder ob man der trauen kann.
Da bin ich jetzt überfragt. Trillian habe ich mir einfach schlichtweg nicht angeschaut, weil ich bin natürlich klar der Jabber-Fanatiker und für dieses Ding muss ich bezahlen, wenn ich dann im legalen Bereich bleiben will, wenn ich Jabber benutzen will. Deswegen keine Ahnung. Aber du hast halt generell zumindest das Problem, dass dein Gegenüber den gleichen Verschlüsselungsmechanismus benutzen muss. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, Trillian ist relativ populär, ist relativ bekannt. Es wird schon so halbwegs sicher sein, sonst hätte man garantiert schon mehr drüber gelesen. Aber so qualifizierte Kommentare abgeben kann ich da einfach nicht.
Also da hat man kurz nachgeschlagen, die Verschlüsselung heißt Secure IM. Das ist so ein Protokoll, was eben auch quasi als Proxy-Server benutzt ist, so zwischengeschaltet. Da gibt es so verschiedene Lösungen, die angeboten werden. Die benutzen dann so relativ bekannte Methoden, also in diesem Fall RSA für die Authentifizierung und dann Glowfish als Verschlüsselung für die eigentliche Datenübertragung dann später. Es gibt also verschiedene Systeme. Ich kann sie jetzt nicht alle aufzählen. Ich würde sagen, das ist an sich schon mal okay. Also das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Verschlüsselung, die den Namen auch verdient. Das Problem ist natürlich, dass es sich nicht so verbreitet hat. Es gibt dann also verschiedenste Ansätze. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser, wenn man das machen kann, als wenn man gar nichts hat.
Ja, man sollte allerdings dann eben aufpassen, dass man so Verschlüsselung auch von jemanden mit Plan nimmt. Also gerade bei ICQ oder so, da haben natürlich ganze Menge Leute das Problem erkannt, dass es erstmal unverschlüsselt ist. Deswegen du findest jede Menge Zusatzprogramme, die sich in der einen oder anderen Form verschlüsseln. Und kürzlich bin ich da auch über ein Programm gestolpert, das auf den ersten Blick super war. Auch gerade Blowfish als Ahr die ganze Liste dranstehen hatte. Der Witz war allerdings, dass sie bei diesem Programm bereits fertig vorgefertigt ins Programm eingegossen, den privaten Schlüssel mitgeliefert haben. Und der war bei allen gleich. Das war also in etwa so, wie wenn du hergehst und ein hochsicheres Haustierschloss verkaufst, aber die haben alle den gleichen Schlüssel. Es ist also einfach lächerlich. Jeder, der da mitlesen will, der holt sich einfach selbst dieses Programm. Der hat dann natürlich den gleichen Private Key. Und damit ist das alles witzlos, obwohl da all die toll klingenden Worte drauf sind. Insofern, keine Ahnung.
Gut, also abwarten, wie sich das mit Trillien weiterentwickelt, ob man da was Böses hört, eventuell.
Ja, wollen wir mal näher anschauen, so weit es dokumentiert ist.
Ja, das ist eher dieses Secure-IM. Das ist eigentlich von Trillien nochmal separat. Da kannst du einfach auch nochmal da nachschauen. Was ich auch jetzt gerade nochmal nachgeschlagen habe, also Apple hat das bei iChat schon vor einer Weile eingeführt und bei AIM ist es jetzt wohl in dem offiziellen Client mittlerweile auch drin, dass sie auch Verschlüsselungen machen, aber das machen die auf der Basis von Zertifikaten. Das ist natürlich so eine Sache mit diesen Zertifikaten, also im Prinzip dieselbe Autorisierungstechnik, Authentifizierungstechnik, wie man das auch bei verschlüsselten Webseiten hat. Das Problem ist, dafür braucht man dann halt auch erstmal so ein Zertifikat und das kriegt man halt nicht einfach so. Bei diesen normalen Verschlüsselungsprotokollen, wie diese SecureIM und auch die anderen, die wir vorher erwähnt haben, da geht das immer alles so ad hoc. Da wird halt ein neuer Schlüssel erzeugt und wenn man eben mit seinem Gegenüber sich darauf einigen kann, dass man jeweils der andere ist, das geht ja in der Regel relativ einfach, dann kann man sich irgendwie sicher sein, dass man es auch mit dem Richtigen zu tun hat. Wenn man aber jetzt mit allen möglichen Leuten im Internet sofort out of the box kommunizieren möchte und auch sicher sein möchte, dass der andere auch derjenige ist, der er vorgibt zu sein, es geht ja nicht nur um die Verschlüsselung, um die Daten unläsbar zu machen, sondern es geht ja auch um die Authentifizierung, um sicher zu sein, dass derjenige, der mit einem kommuniziert, auch derjenige ist, der behauptet, dass er ist, da gibt es eben die verschiedensten Ansätze. Und einer ist eben auf Zertifikatsbasis zu arbeiten und ich halte das für sehr umständlich. Das ist ein schwieriger Weg. Bitte schön.
Du beantwortest meine Frage mehr als natürlich.
Ah, na super. Ich fand die Antwort wahrscheinlich ein bisschen überkomplex.
Hast du was für mich verstanden?
Nicht so richtig viel, nee. Danke für deinen Anruf, Marco.
Da ist hier so ein bisschen das Krankenlager.
Ja, irgendwie ein paar Parzellen verbreitet.
Du bist der Einzige, der noch gesund ist.
Ja, ja, es ist ja auch schick, die werfen sich ständig diese Tabletten über, die Monitorien weg.
Willst du eine Tim?
Alter Herr, ich hab's vorher schon mal gesagt, das ist schick. Ich erinnere mich an meinen Zivi im Altersheim.
Was hast du gerade noch angemerkt?
Es gibt da so ein Web 2.0 Tool, die Richtung... Die leuchtet schon eine rote Lampe über mein Mikro. Das nennt sich QNU und ist so... Ja, Community Support wissen schon.
QNU?
QNU, das ist qunu.com. Wenn ich einen Jabber-Client hab, wenn ich im Jabber online bin, kann ich angeben, ich bin Experte für irgendwelche technischen Dinge. Ich kenne mich mit bestimmten Themen aus. Und dann kann man über diese Website auch entsprechend solche Experten, solche Spezialisten suchen und ihnen Fragen stellen. Also so ein bisschen wie so ein Web-Forum, nur eben mit den Vorteilen von Instant Messaging. Ich kann also direkt dieses Frage- und Antwortspiel entwickeln, dass der Sinn von Instant Messaging ist, dass eben der Vorteil gegenüber E-Mail oder gegenüber Web-Forum ist. Ich hab die sehr schnelle Antwort, ich kann Dialog entwickeln. Ganz interessante Idee, ich hab aber keine Ahnung, wie wir Geld verdienen wollen.
Auf der Webseite steht, Tim needs help with Apache. Und Chantal kann mir helfen. Das heißt, man wird sozusagen online zu irgendjemanden verbunden, der einem weiterhelfen kann, was auch immer.
Genau, das heißt, dieser Community-Ansatz, diese Gemeinschaftsansatz, ich selber kann auch sagen, ich bin Experte für irgendwas. Das sind also keine bezahlten Helfer von der Firma selber, sondern eben von der Community für die Community, um dieses Wort noch ein paar Mal zu verwenden. Ganz interessante Idee, aber wie gesagt, wo man da Geld verdienen will, ist mit Steuern.
Also der Chat ist der Meinung, dass das noch sehr unausgereift sei. Aber was mir dabei auch gerade einfällt, ist, dass Instant Messaging in letzter Zeit auch für Support ein richtiges Thema geworden ist. Verschiedene Firmen bieten jetzt einfach Online-Support über Chat an.
Ja, hat vorhin einer uns Anrufer auch erwähnt.
Stimmt. Und das finde ich eigentlich einen ganz guten Trend, weil dann kann man dann irgendwie sehr viel effizienter bestimmte Dinge, also, naja, manche Sachen kann man wahrscheinlich auch besser am Telefon schildern, aber für manche Sachen mag es auch so ganz gut sein.
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie eigentlich nur, dass du den indischen Akzent nicht hörst.
Weil die Frage ist, ob das wieder nicht wieder so ein Touring-Test ist und ich irgendwie rausfinden muss, ob der Support-Mitarbeiter nicht vielleicht vor Grab ist. Findest du das wirklich? Sind sie sich sicher, dass ihr Computer wirklich kaputt ist? Ich finde das sehr bedauernswert und ich fühle mich mit ihnen.
Ist der Fehler wirklich aufgetreten?
Ja, das ist beunruhigend. Aber trotzdem, das finde ich aber ein schönes Projekt hier mit diesem Verbinden, wobei ja Google gerade seinen Ansatzdienst ja eingestellt hat, aber das hat ja nicht auf Java-Basis funktioniert.
Ja, dafür fängt ja Google gerade mit so einem Dienst an, also insofern wird alles irgendwo nochmal recycelt.
Ja, ist komisch, ne?
Worum? Ich meine, die aktuelle Blase, die funktioniert doch auch so, da es 80% der Ideen schon mal da waren.
Welche Blase?
Keine. Es gibt keine Blase.
Nein, vielleicht gibt es ja eine IEM-Blase.
Das ist cool, überschüttet mich alle mit Geld. Das ist ein ganz guter Plan. Also wenn es da jemanden hat da draußen, gerne doch.
Bei Kuno gibt es übrigens die FAQ Top 10. So und die erste Frage ist, How do you intend making money? Und die Antwort hat er. Da muss ich hier draufklicken, keine Ahnung. Also das war doch deine Frage, oder? Wir haben ganz viele Ideen und wir wollen euch keine Advertisements vor die Nase werfen. Und es wird immer alles ganz kostenlos sein und überhaupt. Sie gehen einfach davon aus, dass wenn das irgendwann mal toll ist und das alles super finden, dass man dann irgendwann bereit ist, dafür zu bezahlen.
Ich verstehe.
Tja, das kann durchaus sein.
Oder jemand korpiert die Idee und macht dann einfach gratis weiter.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie die Idee mit Online-Rechtsberatung bei 990 Nummern. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das jemals durchgesetzt hat. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ha, jetzt wieder die Lala-Alle. Jetzt ist die Musik kaputt gemacht.
Tja, das kommt davon hin, wenn man den Weg klickt und gleichzeitig...
Ach, was denn jetzt hier?
Ich dachte, ich mach schnell Zack-Zack.
Zack-Zack, mal eben so Instant Messaging, Doppelklick und so.
Die haben ja auch beide ihre eigene Musik hier. Da muss man vorher klären, wer jetzt gerade welche Musik dran kommt. Ich glaube, die tauschen Musik und die tauschen...
Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, als würde uns die Sendung hinten raus so ein bisschen ausfransen.
Hast du den Eindruck? Naja, wir sind jetzt einfach zu krank.
Es geht uns nicht gut.
Es geht uns wirklich nicht gut.
Das liegt an dem vielen Instant Messaging.
Genau, Instant Messaging ist nicht gut für dich.
Man könnte ja mal eine Radiosendung mit Instant Messaging machen, so Text to Speech oder so was.
Okay, damit hast du jetzt das Recht auf das Mikrofon weiter zu nutzen.
Aber das können wir doch noch mal festhalten. Also ich finde es toll, mal ehrlich. Ich finde Instant Messaging total toll. Man muss nicht mehr so viel telefonieren, man muss nicht mehr so viele E-Mails schreiben. Und seitdem ich auch noch einen Client habe, der meine Logs irgendwie schön mitführt, behalte ich die Diskussionen auch irgendwie im Kontext. Also ich kann mir einfach mal merken, mit wem ich irgendwie schon mal geredet habe. Das ist natürlich auch ein super großes Problem. Und da kann man euch auch nur noch eins raten. Denkt mal darüber nach, ob ihr nicht eine Möglichkeit habt, eure Festplatten zu verschlüsseln. Und zwar alles. Voll Festplattenverschlüsselung war vor ein paar Chaosradios ja auch schon mal das Thema. Denn in dem Moment, wo man jetzt alles, was man mit irgendwelchen Leuten mitlockt, und viele Programme machen das ja auch, und das ist ja auch für die Fortführung der Kommunikation durchaus hilfreich. Nachteil ist aber, die gesamte Privatkommunikation und vor allem auch so dieser legere Hin- und Herstil, E-Mails sind ja manchmal dann doch ein bisschen formaler, das ist dann alles auf der Festplatte. Und wenn dann irgendwann die böse Copyright-Mafia vorbeikommt und euch für 15 MP3s auf der Festplatte bestrafen will, dann liegen diese Informationen dann halt auch alle offen rum. Und das wollt ihr nicht. Und deswegen müsst ihr aber da was gegen tun.
Das war Chaosradio 119. Instant Messaging war unser Thema. Instant Messaging ist toll. Ein Chaosradio gibt es im Dezember nicht, da gibt es den Kongress. Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im Januar. Das ist der 31. Januar.
Genau. Und zum Kongress könnt ihr euch auch noch informieren. Auf events.ccc.de gibt es einen Blog. Letzter Zeit ein bisschen sträflich vernachlässigt wurde, aber ich habe gesehen, da ist gerade mal wieder was gepostet worden. Und das wird jetzt auch mehr werden, denn der Kongress rückt näher. Und wir möchten mit euch in Verbindung bleiben, wie immer. Die Kongress-Webseite ist auch ein Wiki. Die könnt ihr selber benutzen, um euch da selbst zu organisieren, um euch schonmal warmlaufen zu lassen, zu dokumentieren, was ihr selber für Projekte dort zeigen möchtet. Wir werden übrigens dieses Jahr auch einen neuen Workshopraum haben. Wer also Ideen hat für Workshops, die er auf dem Kongress durchführen möchte und anbieten möchte, oder solche Birds of the Feather Meetings, wo man sich halt mit anderen Leuten zum bestimmten Thema mal austauschen möchte für eine Weile, der kann das dort alles eintragen und reservieren. Und mehr fällt mir jetzt nicht ein zu dem Thema Kongress. Und uns fällt auch nicht mehr ein zum Thema Instant Messaging, auch wenn man dann auch stundenlang drüber reden könnte.
Im Zweifelsfall jabbert uns einfach an.
Genau. Ne, Heugier.
Danke Florian, danke Tim. Im Folgenden der Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Achso, ich dachte ich hätte was falsch gemacht. Ich dachte ich hätte was falsch gemacht. Ihr red ruhig weiter, ihr könnt euch noch ein bisschen hier. Ich wurde ausgestöpselt, wie es immer so ist, da am Chaos Computer Club. Das ist man gewohnt, stöpselt, gedrückt. Knob twiddling sagt man ja in England. In England sagt man ja Knob twiddling. Kennst du das? Also Knöpfchen drehen. Das hat aber so eine schöne Doppeldeutung bei denen. Knob twiddling ist so.